bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur Public Sénat après l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat examine cet
après-midi le projet de loi de réforme
ferroviaire ce texte prévoit de la
réunion de Réseau ferré de France avec
la SNCF dans un groupe public unique
alors cette réforme avait provoqué 13
jours de grève à la SNCF aujourd'hui
elle arrive dans un climat davantage
apaisé au Sénat mais à un an après
l'accident ferroviaire de
Brétigny-sur-Orge en Essonne qui avait
causé la mort de cette personne tous
s'accordent sur la nécessité de
moderniser le réseau ferroviaire un
récent rapport en effet épinglé la SNCF
pour son déficit de maintenance des
réseaux secondaires alors tout de suite
je vous propose d'écouter la discussion
générale de ce texte a commencé par
l'intervention de Frédéric Cuvillier
secrétaire d'État chargé des transports
et puis on se retrouve à 19h pour un
point complet sur l'actualité politique
et parlementaire à tout à l'heure
mesdames et messieurs l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
portant réforme ferroviaire et de la
proposition de loi organique adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relative à la
nomination des dirigeants de la SNCF
la Conférence des Présidents a décidé
que ces deux textes foraient l'objet
d'une discussion générale commune dans
la discussion générale commune la parole
est donc à Monsieur Frédéric Cuvillier
secrétaire des tâches chargé des
transports de la mer et de la Pêche
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
président de commission messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
c'était le 30 octobre 2012 la SNCF
célébrait ses 75 ans d'existence et nous
faisions un constat
celui d'un système ferroviaire en crise
tant dans le fonctionnement entre la
SNCF et RFR en terme financier un
constat aussi exprimé par nos
concitoyens
et illustrer parfois dramatiquement par
des accidents
je pense notamment puisque nous sommes à
quelques jours du terrible accident de
Brétigny combien nous devons mesurer la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre lorsque
nous parlons de la réforme du
ferroviaire de la nécessité de
modernisation de l'enjeu que le
ferroviaire représente pour notre nation
à l'époque j'anais la nécessité d'une
vaste réforme du système ferroviaire une
réforme devant lui redonner du souffle
de la clarté et de l'efficacité nous
avons engagé une très large concertation
de nombreux mois avec l'ensemble des
partis prenantes et le projet de loi fut
présenté en Conseil des ministres ce fut
le 16 octobre dernier
il a été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale le 24 juin après des échanges
intenses constructif
et une actualité qui n'était pas moins
intense
et je sais combien le débat ici
ce fut le cas au commissions mais ce
sera le cas en séance publique sera
d'une réelle
richesse
d'échanges qui doivent nous amener à
peaufiner améliorer le texte encore et
je souhaite que par ce débat par nos
échanges par l'amélioration du
dispositif voté par l'Assemblée
nationale nous puissions adresser un
message de confiance dans le système
ferroviaire français
un espoir en son avenir mais aussi que
nous puissions dessiner un projet qui
soit un projet ambitieux pour le système
ferroviaire français mais aussi pour nos
territoires
ambitieux parce que il exige de la
nation qu'elle s'empare de l'enjeu
ferroviaire qu'elle se réapproprie les
enjeux d'aménagement du territoire je
sais combien vous y êtes sensible et
combien cette une réalité majeure de ce
qui doit apporter de la cohésion
cohésion sociale développement
économique développement industriel sur
nos territoires c'est aussi cela le défi
du ferroviaire c'est aussi cela le
patrimoine ferroviaire national c'est
une réforme qui peut paraître technique
même si elle fut largement vulgarisée
ces dernières semaines
mais qui n'en est pas moins une réforme
de progrès une réforme moderne qui
poursuit un certain nombre d'objectifs 5
le premier objectif est celui d'affirmer
un secteur et un service public renforcé
mieux piloter avec un état qui est
impulse qui agit sous le contrôle de la
nation de ces représentants qui seront
désormais associés le deuxième jeu
objectif et la mise en place d'un
gestionnaire d'infrastructures unifiée
et la création d'un groupe public
qui soit un groupe public industriel
intégré la nouvelle SNCF et qui sera un
agent un enjeu majeur et puissant du
ferroviaire en Europe et dans le monde
car il y a derrière cette notion du
ferroviaire un véritable en jeu je le
disais une véritable vitrine une vitrine
qui est celle du savoir-faire industriel
ferroviaire français le troisième
objectif et la mise en place d'un pacte
national qui doit assurer à terme
l'équilibre financier du système
ferroviaire je sais là aussi combien
vous y êtes sensible
quatrième objectif la nécessité parce
que le monde ferroviaire évolue
d'assurer la construction d'un cadre
social commun à l'ensemble des acteurs
du ferroviaire parce que en effet
en maintenant le statut des cheminots en
unifiant la famille cheminotes nous
devons aussi avoir présent à l'esprit
que le paysage ferroviaire évolue qu'il
existe désormais plus d'une dizaine
d'opérateurs qui agissent dans le
ferroviaire et qu'il serait pas y avoir
des règles
disparaître synonyme de concurrence
déloyale et fossés et j'y reviendrai
enfin la nécessité parce que nous avons
un grand groupe intégré de renforcer le
rôle du régulateur et de garantir
l'impartialité dans l'accès du réseau au
réseau
je vous propose de revenir
pas brièvement mais
les débats nous permettront
d'approfondir les propos de cette
discussion générale sur chacun de ces 5
objectifs
tout d'abord renforcer le service public
c'est une nécessité
il faut redonner du contenu à la notion
même de service public ferroviaire car
je l'indiquais à l'instant le paysage
ferroviaire a beaucoup évolué le service
public ne se limite pas à la seule mise
en oeuvre de convention de service
public c'est aussi et surtout la
sécurité la sûreté la qualité et la
continuité du service public ce sont des
attentes de la part de nos concitoyens
et de usagers
il faut aussi faire respecter par tous
des exigences de ce service public
ferroviaire
il faut que nous puissions favoriser la
coordination entre les différentes
autorités organisatrices l'état bien sûr
mais aussi les régions il nous faut
veiller à la qualité de service à la
sécurité à l'efficacité de tous les
acteurs du ferroviaire et pas à la seule
SNCF il faut redonner une stratégie
ferroviaire à notre pays
il faut en finir avec des décisions qui
nous le savons ont été souvent des
décisions d'opportunités qui ont été
dictées par une vision à court terme le
projet de loi crée un certain nombre
d'instruments d'outils pour nous
permettre de mettre en oeuvre une cette
stratégie
l'illustrera le retour de l'État et plus
largement le retour de la puissance
publique
ce sera la fonction du Haut Comité du
ferroviaire qu'est-ce que le Haut Comité
du ferroviaire c'est un lieu qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui et qui manque
qui permet
l'association des élus des régions des
entreprises des organisations syndicales
bref de tous les acteurs qui sont amenés
à contribuer à la structuration à
l'orientation de l'avenir même du
système ferroviaire en effet ça n'est
pas à la seule
SNCF au seul groupe SNCF historique
certes mais pour autant
n'est pas avec ce monopole de déterminer
ce qui est un enjeu pour la nation toute
entière
remettons les enjeux d'efficacité
économique d'équité territoriales de
puissance industrielle qui sont
stratégiques pour le pays au cœur même
des lieux de décision
le Parlement et vous le savez trop
longtemps tenu à distance pourra ainsi
se saisir s'il le souhaite de ses enjeux
d'avenir le texte le prévoit il nous
faut pouvoir l'amener à prendre position
régulièrement sous forme de surveillance
sur les enjeux financiers sur les enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire sur les
enjeux environnementaux et sociaux du
système ferroviaire l'état fixera enfin
les objectifs du groupe public SNCF je
reviendrai mais il le fera à travers des
contrats qui seront conclus c'est l'état
qui dressera les perspectives et
impulsera la dynamique
l'Assemblée nationale a souhaité
renforcer ses aspects je sais pouvoir
compter sur vous mesdames Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs pour contribuer
au renforcement de la nation et de
l'État dans cette logique cet objectif
et cet enjeu
le deuxième axe de la réforme consiste
en la mise en place d'un gestionnaire
d'infrastructures unifiée et la création
d'un groupe public industriel intégré
réunifiant la famille chemineau
c'est un constat qui est fait par tous
le fait
d'assister une forme d'atomisation des
fonctions d'éclatement des structures
des rôles de mission aujourd'hui RFF
comme la SNCF souffre de ce manque de
cohésion
qui pourtant devait être le gage
d'efficacité le constat est là le
dialogue existe peu ou n'existe plus
entre ces structures les synergies sont
à recréer il est indispensable pour la
France de pouvoir disposer d'un acteur
public majeur sur le plan national mais
aussi au niveau européen et mondial je
vous propose de créer ce groupe public
puissant rassemblant les fonctions en
son sein les fonctions liées à
l'infrastructure d'une part réunit au
sein de SNCF réseau et l'émission de
l'exploitation d'autre part rassembler
au sein de SNCF mobilité
il s'agira je le disais d'un groupe
intégré parce que nous avons besoin que
la famille cheminotte poursuivent les
mêmes objectifs
associe ces forces ses ambitions ces
volonté nous voulons en finir avec ce
séparatisme stérile et souvent très
pénalisant l'intégration permettra de
gagner en efficacité qu'il s'agisse de
l'efficacité technique de l'efficacité
des investissements de la mutualisation
des coûts l'impulsion de la dynamique
ferroviaire viendra de l'établissement
public de tête qui assurera le contrôle
le pilotage stratégique désignera une
partie importante des membres du comité
du conseil d'administration du
transporteur donc de la SNCF mobilité et
du gestionnaire d'infrastructures
c'est-à-dire des SNCF réseau
ce groupe public sera contrôlé par
l'État au plus précisément l'état
reprendra la place qui doit être la
sienne dans la définition d'une
stratégie nationale la SNCF sera dirigée
par un directoire composé du président
SNCF réseau et du président des SNCF
mobilité ces deux présidents seront
nommés par l'État et seront placés sous
l'autorité d'un conseil de surveillance
et de son président qui lui-même sera
choisi par l'État parce que l'oeuvre
ferroviaire est une oeuvre collective
chacun doit y avoir et y trouver sa
place bien sûr il doit y avoir d'autres
représentants et ils sont prévus par les
textes
que je soumets à votre approbation
représentant des régions le rôle des
régions c'est accru ces dernières années
et de façon considérable dans la
structuration une offre ferroviaire de
proximité
mais aussi les salariés et l'État doit
reprendre la main face aux défis qui
sont ceux du ferroviaire
signal fort pour l'efficacité économique
et industrielle SNCF réseau c'est-à-dire
gestionnaire d'infrastructures sera
enfin unifié
aujourd'hui ce sont les agents de la DCF
se sont aussi des agents SNCF Infra ou
encore les agents des FF qui toussent
sont chargés chacun dans leurs entités
de la gestion de l'infrastructure ils
sont tous séparés et éclatés avec je le
disais
une
séparation qui invite à ne pas faire
converger les volonté communes et je
crois pouvoir dire que ils ont même été
opposés
alors je pense que et vous en
conviendrez ça n'est pas en ses parents
des personnes qui doivent travailler
ensemble ce qui gère l'infrastructure
d'une part et ceux qui l'utilisent que
nous pouvons donner les gages d'une plus
grande efficacité c'est bien le
contraire nous devons les rassembler et
là encore l'actualité nous en a donné
une démonstration flagrante nous y
reviendrons dans un débat
je le disais cette entreprise que nous
proposons c'est un groupe unifié qui
permettra de mobiliser toutes les
énergies et de faciliter aussi et c'est
important les mobilités internes de
faire en sorte que là où nous devons
décider d'investissement ce soir en
cohérence avec le service et que nous
soyons sensibles au fait que
investissement est utilisation des
infrastructures puissent aller de pair
le troisième axe de la réforme et la
conclusion d'impact national pour sauver
et assurer financièrement la pérennité
de ce qui est pour nous un modèle de
service public ferroviaire national
aujourd'hui nous en sommes conscients ce
sont automatiquement chaque année plus
d'un virgule 5 milliards d'euros de
dettes nouvelles générées par le système
et même au-delà si l'on intègre la
construction actuelle de quatre lignes à
grande vitesse financées par RFF en
recourant à l'impôt
ainsi
nous avons face à nous ce défi
un certain nombre d'infrastructures ont
été financés engageant l'avenir même du
ferroviaire alors le gouvernement
propose dans le projet de loi de stopper
l'alourdissement du fardeau de la dette
et pour cela un certain nombre de
dispositions nécessiteront la
contribution de tous et l'engagement de
la nation
tout d'abord il convient de cesser de
faire financer les grands travaux par
RFF de le faire par emprunt sans que
nous ne soyons à même de savoir si ceci
pourront être remboursés par RFF
ces dernières années c'est un constat RF
a été soumise à l'exigence de l'État
l'État s'est déchargé sur RFM pour
financer les LGV quel en est la
conséquence de moindre financement pour
l'entretien et la modernisation de nos
lignes de train du quotidien et vous en
êtes tous les
témoins chacun sur vos territoires
m'interpeller pour m'indiquer combien
tel ou tel nécessité de remise à niveau
et le constat qui m'accueillait lors de
ma nomination il y a plus de deux ans
qui était celui de l'École polytechnique
de Lausanne sur le niveau de dégradation
du réseau ferroviaire en était à constat
supplémentaire nous devons assurer le
maintien au niveau la modernisation le
renouvellement
et pour cela
il ne saurait être question de passer
cette réalité au second plan parce qu'il
s'agit du patrimoine national parce
qu'il s'agit de ce qui doit être
préservé ce qui doit être développé mais
aussi modernisé
nous avons résolument par ce texte
souhaité
mettre un terme à cette politique la
course en avant qui s'est affranchi de
toute obligation de financement qui a
laissé porter aux générations futures
une dette qui aujourd'hui est lesté de
plus de 40 milliards
depuis 2 ans
j'ai tenu sur l'autorité des premiers
ministres Jean-Marc Ayrault et Manuel
Valls un redéfinir clairement les
priorités en matière de politique de
transport
priorité a été donnée au transport du
quotidien citons deux exemples tout
d'abord le schéma national des
infrastructures de transport avec le
célèbre rapport du rond et la mise en
place ce qui nous concerne
prioritairement d'un plan ambitieux de
modernisation du réseau ferroviaire
mais ce plan de modernisation n'a de
sens que si nous avons un regard qui est
un regard d'ensemble que si nous
restructurons le système ferroviaire que
si nous avons un souci de l'efficacité
économique que nous avons le souci de
mettre en place une véritable stratégie
d'investissement de l'ensemble du
système
nous devons également optimiser le
savoir-faire la capacité la compétence
nous devons faire en sorte que cette
ingénierie cette capacité qu'il s'agisse
de la maîtrise d'ouvrage de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre des agents des FF de la SNCF
soit réunis coordonnées optimisé et
donne enfin la fierté retrouvée à la
famille cheminots deuxième disposition
l'état prendra part à cet effort
financier
imaginez pour ceux qui ne le savent pas
car ce n'est pas vulgarisé que l'État
reçoit aujourd'hui des dividendes sur le
ferroviaire alors même que le
ferroviaire est endetté à plus de 40
milliards d'euros
il faut donc remettre de la logique il
faut donc être responsable et nous
proposons donc le reversement des
dividendes du transporteur vers le
gestionnaire d'infrastructures et nous
proposons également la compensation
fiscale au sein du groupe des excédents
et des déficits
le Transporteur et le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures ainsi
participeront à cet effort par des
mesures d'optimisation d'efficacité de
meilleure organisation du travail
enfin nous vous proposerons une règle
une règle qui soit celle du
rétablissement des équilibres financiers
qui fassent l'objet d'un contrat avec
l'État ce pacte national n'a pas pour
objectif ni pour effet comme je l'ai
entendu ces dernières semaines de
dégrader les conditions de travail
dégradées les niveaux de rémunération
des cheminots en particulier ne remet
pas en cause de statut des cheminots
cela a été une contreveillé irritée
véhiculée à des fins de mobilisation et
là au contraire pour
ambition de préserver de renforcer et
développer le service ferroviaire
français
le projet de loi donne ainsi les
instruments aux futurs groupes pour
stabiliser en disant son endettement cet
effort est un effort indispensable une
règle pas le fardeau de la dette
historique j'en conviens l'État n'a pas
aujourd'hui et vous le savez les moyens
de reprendre une partie de cette dette
d'ailleurs c'est une question de méthode
il y aurait aucun sens à reprendre une
partie de la dette sans avoir
préalablement remis le système dans une
logique vertueuse c'est précisément ce
que propose ce projet de loi il prévoit
donc que le gouvernement remette au
Parlement un rapport sur les moyens pour
traiter la question de l'évolution de la
dette historique monsieur le rapporteur
cher michel Teston je sais que vous êtes
sensible cette question vous avez
souhaité d'ailleurs en commission aller
plus loin et je salue cette position
quatrième axe de la réforme le volet
social
que l'agent tendus là encore ces
dernières semaines
j'ai conscience des inquiétudes elles
ont été exprimées parfois même véhiculé
utilisé et certains ont fait dire au
projet de loi ce qu'il ne disait pas et
cette nouvelle lecture me permettra d'y
revenir et d'en faire démonstration
devant vous
ces inquiétudes je ne les ignore pas et
précisément c'est parce qu'elles
existent que nous souhaitons y apporter
réponse
la France ne peut sans conséquence
s'engager dans une bataille sociale du
rail et depuis deux ans c'est cet esprit
de dialogue qui s'est imposé avec la
volonté de travailler avec l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales avec les
groupes parlementaires vous en avez été
les acteurs les témoins c'est ce souci
du dialogue social qui a animé mon
travail celui de mon équipe avec pour
seul objectif de faire réussir le
ferroviaire français du quotidien
je souhaite réaffirmer avec force ma
conviction et ma méthode celle de
l'importance du diabolologue social pour
accompagner les changements ils sont
indispensables changements dont la SNCF
a besoin tout le monde en est conscient
les usagers les premiers mais les
acteurs eux-mêmes en sont
quotidiennement
conscient et là encore nous témoignent
de la nécessité de réforme je souhaite
d'ailleurs je le dis avec beaucoup
là aussi de conviction mais aussi de
solennité je souhaite saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité je souhaite remercier les
organisations syndicales représentatives
qui ont souhaité s'engager en signant
les accords de modernisation le 13 juin
dernier
ces accords de modernisation voyez vous
vous trompez sur le ministre
permettez-moi de répondre à votre
interpellation il est des syndicats qui
s'engagent qui signent qui négocient et
qui permettent d'éviter des conflits
sociaux qui peuvent en effet être
préjudiciable aux usagers je salue donc
cet esprit de responsabilité je suis
persuadé que vous n'aviez pas bien
entendu le sens de ma formule sinon vous
auriez approuvé mes propos les accords
qui ont été signés sont des accords qui
se sont traduits par des avancées elles
ont été d'ailleurs actées adoptées
améliorer à l'Assemblée nationale
notamment pour ceux qui concerne les
termes d'intégration sociale du futur
groupe
le groupe disposera d'instances
représentatives du personnel centralisé
de déléguer syndicaux centraux portant
la négociation sociale au niveau
transversal
cette intégration se fera aussi par la
gestion des réformes des ressources
humaines qui se rappelaient au niveau de
l'Épic de tête avec et c'est important
la gestion coordonnée des parcours et de
la mobilité au sein même de cette grande
entreprise de ce grand groupe public il
s'agit tout simplement de donner
concrétisation à mes propos et à notre
volonté c'est à dire de permettre à
chaque cheminot par la mobilité sociale
par un parcours professionnel d'avoir
des perspectives de progression de
changer de métier de changer de
formation de pouvoir apporter mais aussi
apprendre de donner des perspectives
nouvelles à sa carrière de pouvoir faire
en sorte que la découverte d'autres
métiers soit un signe de modernisation
de progression de progression
individuelle et professionnelle cela
sera garanti par ce texte
il s'agit d'accompagner l'ambition
collective
celle du futur groupe public SNCF mais
aussi les aspirations légitimes de
chacun de ces salariés le volet social
est important car c'est l'avenir du
service public et cet avenir du service
public ne peut se faire sans qu'il
existe un cadre social commun à
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
ferroviaire
vous le savez depuis maintenant un
certain nombre d'années le ferroviaire
est désormais pour ce qui est de sa
partie fret ouvert à la concurrence
pourtant ceux qui ont été les promoteurs
de cette ouverture à la concurrence non
pas pris un certain nombre de
précautions qui désormais déstabilise le
secteur ferroviaire fret je pense
notamment à des précautions permettant
d'éviter la mise en place d'une
concurrence qui ne soit pas faussée
évitez qu'il y ait des règles
disparaître qui s'appliquent à chacun
des acteurs il faut donc qu'il y ait des
règles sociales qui soient des règles
sociales communes qui ne laisse pas la
charge au secteur public et les profits
au secteur privé
ces erreurs qui ont été commises lors de
la libéralisation du fret je souhaite
qu'elle ne soit pas reproduite d'abord
parce qu'un calendrier européen se
présentera à nous et nous y reviendrons
que pour défendre un service public
encore faut-il le moderniser et le
préparer
à ces rendez-vous qui conditionneront
son existence et son avenir et que l'on
ne peut pas laisser la libre concurrence
s'exercer sans même qu'il y a un minimum
de règles qui s'imposent à tous c'est
ainsi que nous pourrons avoir une
véritable politique publique ferroviaire
respectueuse des enjeux je le disais de
sécurité d'aménagement du territoire
mais aussi d'une vision qui doit être
une vision partagée industrielle et de
développement économique
par ailleurs je n'ai pas souhaité et là
encore je répondrai certainement à des
interrogations qui ne manqueront pas de
d'être posé je n'ai pas souhaité et je
l'ai dit dès les premiers jours de ma
prise de fonction
devancé une mise en concurrence
sans que nous n'ayons préalablement
permis à l'entreprise nationale d'être
efficace d'être compétitive ne pas
laisser l'ouverture du marché sans qu'un
certain nombre de garde-fous
s'appliquent à chacun c'est ma méthode
notamment
la raison pour laquelle ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui n'a pas souhaité anticiper
des dates d'ailleurs forte incertaine
puisque lorsque là encore je prenais mes
premières fonctions ministres des
Transports il m'était indiqué un
calendrier européen opposable alors même
que celui-ci ne l'était pas preuve en
est nous n'avons toujours pas de façon
certaine les dates de l'ensemble de la
libéralisation du secteur et que par
ailleurs c'était ne pas penser à
peut-être d'autres périodes ont illustré
l'absence de vigilance de l'état du
gouvernement de la France au niveau
européen mais que désormais nous sommes
dans l'exigence
et que lorsque nous engageons des
négociations au niveau européen des
discussions avec le commissaire européen
ça n'est pas pour reculer mais c'est
bien pour au contraire faire triompher
une vision qui est la nôtre et ne pas
anticiper des réformes qui nous seraient
imposées sans même que nous fassions
valoir un certain nombre des principes
qui sont ceux que j'expose devant vous
ainsi contrairement à un certain nombre
d'esprits pétris du dogme libéral je
n'ai pas souhaité anticiper des
échéances et je souhaite encore les
négocier pieds à pied au niveau européen
je veux des règles qui soient
protectrices
qui soit appliqué à tous nous devons
donc proposer de construire un cadre
social qui soit un cadre social commun
personne ne dit jamais autre chose
lorsqu'il s'agit de la concurrence la
concurrence elle doit se faire en règle
égale pour chacun des acteurs encore
faut-il que nous soyons en situation de
pouvoir les imposer ses règles à tous et
ne pas une fois encore condamné sous
prétexte que il y aurait une certaine
aversion pour le secteur public de lui
faire porter la charge de ce que peut
représenter un service public le coût du
service public et laissant des lignes
qui seraient bénéficiaires à la libre
concurrence qui deviendrait d'un coup
d'un seul vertueuse non parce que
derrière vous le savez sont des
questions je les ai indiqué je le dis
d'autant plus solennellement devant les
sénateurs qu'il s'agit des questions
intimement liées à la réalité des
territoires et de la sécurité
de ce qu'attendre les usagers en termes
d'équilibre de ces territoires
je vous propose donc disais de
construire un cadre social commun qui
porte à la fois sur l'organisation du
travail
compatible avec le maintien du statut
des cheminots et nous devons saisir ces
enjeux majeurs pour ne pas laisser aux
partisans d'un libéralisme européen
l'occasion de sacrifier ce qui
représente l'enjeu de l'équilibre des
territoires et qui serait sacrifiée au
profit de logique purement financière
la bataille du rail elle est désormais
économique et se joue et vous le savez
au niveau européen le projet de loi et
je le dis et je l'assume une réelle
avancée contre un certain nombre de
velléités je les entends à chacun des
conseils des ministres européens mais
pas seulement d'ailleurs parfois dans le
cadre interne et qu'on des volontés
contre un certain nombre de velléités
d'une concurrence déchaînée non ce
projet de loi au contraire souhaite
apporter une forme de protection de
renforcement de mettre en place
l'armature d'un édifice public sécurisé
prêt à affronter l'avenir non pas se
tourner vers le passé y être nostalgique
mais au contraire assurer la
modernisation du ferroviaire dernier
point
nous aurons assuré que le cadre de la
régulation s'applique et quelques mots
avant que nous n'y venions y compris sur
des amendements qui ne manquent pas
d'être déposé et débattus grâce à un
régulateur extérieur puisque lorsque
nous souhaitons la puissance d'un groupe
public intégré il faut que nous
puissions avoir un régulateur qui
réponde là pour le coup un certain
nombre de garanties d'accès au réseau
l'accès aux réseaux dans des conditions
transparentes le régulateur aura un rôle
central dans ce nouveau dispositif il
devra veiller à ce que le système ne
dérive pas et il sera attentif ce seront
ces compétences à ce que la réalité
financière soit et la stratégie la
directive
financière soit scrupuleusement maintenu
je suis aussi attaché à son indépendance
c'est pourquoi par exemple je soutenu
cet état l'Assemblée nationale des
initiatives visant à avoir un avis
conforme de la RAF non seulement pour le
péage mais aussi pour les redevances
gare
l'existence d'un régulateur fort est une
contrepartie je le disais nécessaire un
groupe ferroviaire fort pour terminer
mes propos je tiens à dire ici
que je sais le rôle qui est le mien dans
la responsabilité de ce débat
la responsabilité qui est celle que j'ai
devant vous qui est à la fois la
nécessité et je l'ai fait de défendre un
héritage commun
qui est l'héritage humain aussi d'une
histoire du ferroviaire qui est
intimement lié avec le patrimoine de
notre nation sa réalité ces territoires
mais aussi la nécessité qui est la nôtre
en
évoquant et en abordant ce texte de
permettre que cette histoire ne soit pas
une histoire du passé et qu'elle puisse
au contraire se poursuivre et
s'amplifier il y a dans notre histoire
une symbolique qui est très forte du
ferroviaire il y a dans notre pays une
réalité qui est très forte de cette
structuration du pays grâce au
ferroviaire
c'est celle de l'image du progrès qui a
été initié notamment en première partie
du 19e siècle mais nous ne sommes plus à
ces périodes de fondation nous sommes
peut-être un nouveau tournant pour le
ferroviaire une forme de refondation
nous devons aborder un contexte qui est
un contexte européen voire mondialisé
nous avons la réalité de l'industrie
ferroviaire française qui est une grande
richesse et que nous soutenons et pour
lequel nous devons avoir une vision
l'état stratège de soutien d'impulsion
imaginé tout de même mais là aussi les
débats qui seront
là encore enrichie de vos expériences
que lorsque nous parlons des lignes
nationales lorsque nous parlons des
trains d'équilibre du territoire nous
nous sommes confrontés à une réalité
c'est que d'un point de vue industriel
il n'existe il n'existait pas de train
sus de remplir ses missions pour le
remplacement des corails des fameuses
intersités et que l'industrie
ferroviaire elle-même n'avait pas
anticipé ce que pouvait être une vision
stratégique de l'organisation des
réseaux de la complémentarité entre le
train régional le train national et la
grande vitesse il fallait bien qu'il y
ait donc une impulsion nous donnons les
lieux de cette impulsion et je remercie
Arnaud Montebourg d'ailleurs d'avoir à
mes côtés présidé à plusieurs reprises
le comité stratégique ferroviaire
d'avoir donné des budgets nécessaires
Monsieur Louis ne pourra pas
méconnaître cette réalité nous on pourra
pas nous priver des discours dans
d'autres responsabilités qui sont les
siennes qui souvent mettent en exergue
l'action du gouvernement dans ce domaine
ferroviaire ne pourra pas vous priver de
se satisfait site parfois nous ne sommes
pas parfaits nous pouvons encore
progresser mais avec pour la première
fois nous avons une véritable impulsion
donnée preuve en est la volonté exprimée
par le Premier ministre Jean-Marc
Ayrault qui a été confirmé par Emmanuel
Valls de pouvoir pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans
voté et commander et financements de
renouvellement à perspective de 2025 de
l'ensemble des trains d'équilibre du
territoire 30 ans qu'il n'y avait pas eu
la moindre commande le moindre
renouvellement de matériel roulant et le
tout en pleine discussions cohésion avec
les acteurs économiques lorsque nous
lançons les autoroutes ferroviaires
dois-je parler là aussi de la stratégie
qui est la nôtre de pouvoir accompagner
les enjeux industriels des territoires
autour de ces grandes autoroutes nous
sauvons l'industrie du ferroviaire et
j'aurais l'occasion d'enlever les tous
prochains jours d'aller visiter les
industries l'or qui là encore était
pleinement
dépendant de la commande publique nous
l'avons honoré nous avons impulsé une
démarche nouvelle nous avons sauvé
l'emploi et nous avons mis un fond qui
est un fond dédié trop ferroviaire
permettant sur le modèle de
l'aéronautique de faire en sorte que les
grands acteurs puissent accompagner les
PME les ETI et de pouvoir créer en
quelque sorte un véritable cluster des
activités ferroviaires nous sommes des
leaders mondiaux c'est vrai des
infrastructures c'est vrai des coeurs de
voix c'est vrai du matériel roulant nous
avons encore il y a quelques jours des
grands marchés qui sont au démarche
ferroviaires urbain ou non qui ont été à
l'étranger gagné par les opérateurs
français nous devons donc nous-mêmes
poursuivre impulsé donner une chance
supplémentaire faire en sorte que nous
soyons et nous mettions le système
ferroviaire n'ont pas hors de son temps
comme j'ai pu l'entendre parfois où j'ai
peut-être eu à le regretter de la part
d'un certain nombre de positions les au
contraire de le placer face à des défis
qui sont des défis d'avenir de le faire
avec conviction avec
respect par rapport à tous ceux qui ont
la compétence et qui mettent à la
disposition de cette industrie et de ses
acteurs
nous ne sommes pas favorables nous
l'avons démontré et nous avons gagné
cette discussion européenne alors même
que d'autres
vous mettez
en prévention sur d'éventuelles euro
incompatibilité de texte qui eux-mêmes
n'étaient pas opposable à la volonté de
la France nous avons apaisé de tout
notre poids au niveau européen nous
avons à faire dominé ce qui est notre
vision du ferroviaire c'est notre
responsabilité comme grande nation
ferroviaire européenne nous nous sommes
opposés à un modèle unique avec des
règles uniques souvent destructrices
nous avons souhaité au contraire que
nous n'ayons pas à nous affranchir de la
réalité du patrimoine même ferroviaire
que nous puissions conjuguer
compétitivité réalité économique filière
industrielle et que nous ayons notre
capacité au niveau européen à organiser
la gouvernance même du système
ferroviaire là où d'autres essayer de
nous imposer un système d'organisation
unique et bien la France qui pendant
trop longtemps a été absente de ces
enjeux ces dernières années je crois
pouvoir le dire à retrouver sa place au
niveau européen dans les discussions
européennes encore fallut-il quelle
occupe qu'elle soit présente et qu'elle
soit exigeante encore fallait-il qu'elle
sache nouer les alliances nécessaires
avec les grandes nations ferroviaires je
pense à nos amis allemands avec lesquels
nous avons réussi à travailler sur la
vision qui est la nôtre des différents
paquets ferroviaires et de
l'organisation de la gouvernance
européenne et nous avons fait reculer ce
qui devait s'imposer à l'Europe du
ferroviaire une vision unique qui était
celle de libéralisme que j'ai qualifié
tout à l'heure voilà le message que je
souhaite vous adresser voilà le message
que je souhaite porter devant vous
devant le représentant de la nation
je souhaite en effet que nous puissions
refonder le système ferroviaire redonner
force et vigueur redonner vertus mais
aussi confiance en le service public
nous devons aujourd'hui tracer des
perspectives qui sont celles de progrès
et donner à la France le maillage
nécessaire tantiniel économique mais
aussi humain de ce que le service public
peut apporter à chacun de nos
territoires voilà l'enjeu de ce projet
de référence ferroviaire je sais qu'il
va nous occuper de longues heures de
longues journées dans un climat
que je souhaite parce qu'il est apaisé
le débat et le dialogue social l'a
emporter c'est ce qui est pour moi la
priorité le dialogue social est celui
qui a permis de faire prendre conscience
de ce que l'avenir du ferroviaire mérité
d'une mobilisation commune avec une
volonté de modernisation mais aussi des
réponses aux attentes de nos concitoyens
je vous remercie
du développement durable
c'est le sénateur vous savez la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission du développement durable
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des finances chers et chers collègues
la réforme ferroviaire est nécessaire et
urgente elle assure la cohérence du
système ferroviaire tout en étant euro
compatible
comment en effet
ne pas replacer cette réforme dans son
contexte européen des discussions sont
en cours autour d'un quatrième paquet
ferroviaire avec de nouvelles étapes
d'ouverture à la concurrence
ce projet de loi n'a pas pour objet
d'anticiper ces étapes qu'à titre
personnel je n'appelle pas forcément de
mes vœux ceci étant
nous devons nous préparer à cette
échéance faute de quoi la SNCF risque de
connaître les mêmes déconvenues que sa
filiale frette SNCF lors de la
libéralisation du fret pour cela nous
devons faire disparaître les trois
handicaps dont souffre notre système
ferroviaire
premier handicap la séparation de la
gestion de l'infrastructure entre deux
entités RF et la SNCF ainsi que la
prévue la loi de 1997 cette séparation
inédite dans le monde n'est aujourd'hui
plus défendu par personne comme l’ont
montré les conclusions les assises du
ferroviaire organisées à l'automne 2011
elle a été à l'origine de nombreux
dysfonctionnements dans l'entretien du
réseau sur coup de gestion manque de
réactivité dilution des responsabilités
etc
deuxième handicap une dette colossale
pèse sur notre système ferroviaire elle
atteint aujourd'hui 44 milliards d'euros
au total dont 37 milliards pour RF la
réforme de 1997 a laissé ce problème
sans solution puisque RFF a été
considéré dès le départ comme une
structure de défaisance de la dette
l'État qui cherchait à maîtriser son
endettement pour satisfaire aux critères
de Maastricht n'avait pas souhaité
reprendre une partie de la dette de la
SNCF contrairement à ce qui avait été
fait en Allemagne quelques années
auparavant pour la Deutsche ban réseau
ferré le France est donc retrouvé avec
plus de 20 milliards d'euros de dettes
issus de la SNCF sans qu'aucune mesure
structurelle n'était prise pour réduire
sa progression
par la suite la double dérive des coups
de gestion du réseau existant et de
développement des lignes nouvelles
a-t-on dû à l'emballement de la dette
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui si l'on
ne fait rien la dette du réseau pourrait
atteindre près de 70 milliards d'euros
en 2025 cette situation n'est pas
soutenable troisième handicap notre
système ferroviaire a souffert d'une
insuffisante préparation à l'ouverture à
la concurrence du fret ferroviaire
en l'absence d'un cadre social homogène
cette impréparation a conduit à un
rapide effondrement de l'activité de
fret et SNCF ces handicap ont été
d'autant plus dommageables que les temps
n'a pas su ou pas pu jouer le rôle
d'arbitre qui aurait dû être le sien
dans les conflits entre RFA et la SNCF
il sait peu impliqué dans les questions
stratégiques laissant ainsi
d'importantes marges de manœuvre aux
deux établissements ces éléments de
contexte doivent suffire à démontrer
l'absolué de cette réforme et urgence
qu'il y a
ce projet de loi apporte des réponses
concrètes aux difficultés que je viens
d'évoquer il marque le retour de l'État
stratège il crée un gestionnaire
d'infrastructures unifiées SNCF réseau
qui rassemble en son sein les activités
aujourd'hui exercées par RFF la DCF et
SNCF Infra
il insère le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures SNCF réseau et
l'exploitons l'exploitant pardon des
services de transport ferroviaire SNCF
mobilité dans un même groupe public
ferroviaire la SNCF dans le jargon
européen on parle d'une structure
verticalement intégrée il s'agit en
quelque sorte de mettre en place une
holding ferroviaire à la française tout
en conservant le statut des pics de ces
différentes composantes l'expérience
passée et la réalité du terrain ont un
effet montré que seul un système intégré
pouvait être réellement efficace pour un
fonctionnement optimal du réseau les
problématiques d'entretien du réseau et
les contraintes d'exploitation ne
peuvent pas être systématiquement
dissociés c'est d'ailleurs une
organisation similaire qu'a choisi la
Deutsche ban
ce modèle intégré qui a pourtant fait
ses preuves n'a pas eu dans les premiers
temps monsieur le ministre la rappeler
les faveurs de la Commission européenne
qui voulaient aller jusqu'à l'interdire
fort heureusement vous avez chez
Monsieur le Ministre démontrer qu'il
s'agissait d'un modèle pertinent face au
modèle opposé d'une séparation intégrale
entre la gestion de l'infrastructure
d'une part et l'exploitation des
services de transport d'autre part et
bien nous revient désormais d'appuyer la
position que vous avez prise en adoptant
ce texte en parallèle cette intégration
ce texte offre concurrents de la SNCF de
réelle garantie d'indépendance dans
l'exercice des fonctions dites
essentielles à savoir la tarification et
la location des sillons en conformité
avec le droit européen existe
la RAF dont le rôle a été
considérablement renforcé surtout après
l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale contrôlera le respect de ces
exigences ce texte comporte également
des mesures fortes destinées à mettre
fin à la dérive financière du système le
pilotage du système ferroviaire sera
renforcé puisque le projet de loi
organise de le retour de l'État stratège
émet en place les outils destinés à
maîtriser l'endettement du système les
contrats signés entre l'État et les
différents épices du groupe ainsi qu'une
règle de maîtrise de l'endettement donne
l'application sera surveillée par la RAF
l'autorité se voit ainsi dotée d'un
nouveau rôle qu'on pourrait qualifier de
régulateur économique du système enfin
ce projet de loi pose les bases d'un
cadre social commun à l'ensemble des
salariés de la branche ferroviaire qui
sera élaboré pour l'essentiel par les
partenaires sociaux
mais sur la base d'un décret socle
l'Assemblée nationale à la
substantiellement et utilement compléter
ce projet de loi cela puissions de son
rapporteur Gilles Savary dont je
voudrais souligner devant vous la
compétence et l'engagement
la commission du développement durable
du Sénat a de son côté préserver les
équilibres atteint à l'Assemblée
nationale tout en complétant le texte
sur plusieurs points à l'article premier
les députés ont largement pris en compte
les aspirations des cheminots en
renforçant l'intégration du groupe
public ferroviaire ce travail important
a été salué par la commission du
développement durable du Sénat il est
essentiel que nous conservions les gages
obtenus en termes de réunification de la
famille cheminante les députés ont aussi
complété les dispositions du texte
relatives à la gouvernance en ajoutant
au comité du système de transport
ferroviaire un comité des opérateurs du
réseau composé des clients de SNCF
réseau
dans ce domaine notre commission a prévu
la participation des associations de
protection de l'environnement agréé au
comité du système de transport
ferroviaire elle a aussi prévu à
l'article 2 que le Haut Comité délibert
annuellement sur des recommandations
d'action et les propositions d'évolution
du contrat signé entre SNCF réseau et
les temps notre commission a salué les
différentes mesures visant à renforcer
l'information et le contrôle du
Parlement sur le système de transport
ferroviaire tel que la transmission
systématique au Parlement des projets de
contrat signés entre l'État et les
établissements du groupe public
ferroviaire ou la mise en place d'un
schéma national des services de
transport nous y avons ajouté la
présence d'un député et d'un sénateur au
conseil de surveillance de la SNCF
à l'article 2
l'Assemblée nationale a précisé la règle
de maîtrise de l'endettement du réseau
en distinguant d'une part les
investissements liés à la maintenance du
réseau c'est à dire les investissements
de renouvellement d'autre part les
investissements de développement du
réseau notre commission a adopter
plusieurs amendements de clarification
rédactionnelle dont deux importants
présentés par François Patriat au nom de
la commission des finances au même
article 2 notre commission a adopté un
amendement identifiant SNCF réseau comme
le propriétaire unique de l'ensemble des
lignes du réseau ferré national il nous
a semblé nécessaire d'écarter toute
perspective de démantèlement du réseau
ferré national même si certains
délégations strictement encadrées sont
possibles
dans le même dans le même esprit nous
avons accepté les articles de bis A et
de bisbées qui ouvre la possibilité aux
régions de racheter certaines petites
lignes d'intérêt purement locales afin
de ne pas les laisser se détériorer et
qui permettent aux régions de créer ou
d'exploiter des lignes d'intérêt
régional sont aussi réglés certains cas
ponctuels comme celui de la ligne digne
Nice
dont la région PACA pourra devenir
gestionnaire de pleine compétences comme
le précédent cet article ne remet pas en
cause l'unicité du réseau national
puisque seul des infrastructures
d'intérêts locales sont visées l'article
de terre prévoit la remise d'un rapport
du Gouvernement au Parlement sur les
solutions à mettre en oeuvre pour
traiter de l'évolution de la dentisterie
du système ferroviaire notre commission
a souhaité inclure explicitement dans ce
rapport l'examen d'une reprise par
l'état de tout ou partie de la dette de
SNCF réseau le portage par essentiel
réseau d'une dette qui ne peut amortir
et dont l'état est de facto le garant il
est en effet pas légitime cette dette
représente chacun des charges
financières considérables qui
gagneraient être investi dans
l'entretien et la régénération du réseau
alors article 4 les pouvoirs de la RAF
ont été sensiblement étendues par
l'Assemblée nationale son avis conforme
sur les redevances d'infrastructures a
été rétablie et étendu au redevances des
gares et relatives à l'accès aux
infrastructures de services l'autorité
sera en outre chargée de veiller à ce
que les décisions de la SNCF respectent
l'indépendance de SNCF réseau dans
l'exercice des fonctions essentielles
nous n'avons pas modifié les
dispositions relatives au collège de la
RAF qui conservera sept membres comme
aujourd'hui trois d'entre eux le
président et les deux vices présidents
nous met par les présidents de
l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat exerçant
leur fonction à temps plein notre
commission du développement durable a
par ailleurs inscrit dans la loi le
principe de la publicité de l'ensemble
des propositions à vie et décisions de
la RAF en conformité avec la directive
2012 34 de l'Union européenne
établissant un espace ferroviaire unique
européen à l'article 5
qui traite de SNCF mobilité
les députés ont notamment prévu une
décomposition par ligne de compte TER en
commission nous avons précisé que cette
décomposition sera définie pour chaque
région et non dans le cas de référentiel
commun nous avons aussi précisé que le
transport ferroviaire de marchandises
doit
figurer au nom des objectifs à signer à
SNCF mobilité dans le cas de son contrat
décennale avec l'État afin de mieux
prendre en compte la situation très
préoccupante du Fred ferroviaire
l'article 5 bis constituait un apport
important de nos collègues députés il
répond un certain nombre de
revendications phares des régions alors
confiant un rôle de chef de fil en
matière d'aménagement des gardes
d'intérêt régional en Europe troyant la
liberté tarifaire sous réserve du
maintien des tarifs sociaux nationaux en
permettant de leur transférer la
propriété du matériel roulant et en
imposant une présentation comptable
séparée des contrats de
l'équilibre trouver sur ces points
correspond à une solution de compromis
que nous souhaitions également et nous
assemble les judicieux de l'accepter en
l'état nous avons toutefois souhaité
assurer l'effectivité de ces
dispositions à l'introduisant à
l'article 5 TER une ressource fiscale
dédiée au financement de la compétence
transport des régions on observe en
effet un décalage croissant entre les
compétences confiées aux régions qui
s'accroissent au fur et à mesure des
réformes et leurs ressources propres qui
diminue fortement depuis la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle l'option retenue
par la Commission et celle proposée par
Jean-Jacques Fillol et Roland riche
notamment d'un versement de transport
interstitiel et qui ne concerne que les
territoires situés hors périmètre de
transport urbain les PTU et plafonné à 0
55% de la masse salariale
alors mes chers et chers collègues il
n'existent pas de solutions parfaites en
la matière mais celle que nous avons
retenu nous assemblez moins pénalisante
pour la compétitivité des entreprises
que celles d'un versement transport
additionnel qui viendrait s'ajouter aux
2% déjà quitté de la plupart des grandes
agglomérations nous avons également
introduit un nouvel article 6 bis 1 qui
prévoit la mise en place d'une
protection spécifique des circulations
ferroviaires contre les effets
perturbateurs des ondes émises par les
installations radioélectriques tierce ce
problème déjà évoqué par Gilles Savary
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas pu être
traitée dans le cas de la propulsion de
Loire relative à l'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques et il est donc
important de le régler ici
autre point important le volet sécurité
et sur te ferroviaire l'article 6ter a
impose une remontée à l'établissement
public de sécurité ferroviaire le PSF
des événements mettant encore la
sécurité ferroviaire et prévoit un
mécanisme de sanction en cas de
manquement à cette obligation je suis
favorable à cette mesure qui préfigure
l'instauration d'une culture du
compte-rendu compte-rendu des forces
enjeux de la sécurité ferroviaire après
le terrible accident de
Brétigny-sur-Orge il convient d'afficher
la mobilisation de l'ensemble des
acteurs du système ferroviaire dans ce
domaine l'article 6ter pose le principe
de libre accès des forces de l'ordre aux
véhicules ferroviaires pour l'exercice
de leur mission de protection de leur
public et la sortie d'une sanction
pénale
cette mesure vise à faciliter la
présence policière à bord des trains
nationaux comme étranger alors l'article
7 qui rattache la surveillance générale
la juge de la SNCF à l'épique de tête
les députés ont fait en sorte que la
mobilisation de la juge soit
systématique pour l'ensemble des
opérateurs dès lors que les tarifs
associés à ces prestations sont
transparents non discriminatoires et
contrôlés par un avis conforme de la RAF
cette solution me paraît efficiente de
bon sens l'article 9 bis a été introduit
par la commission du développement
durable de l'Assemblée nationale en
coordination avec le dépôt de la
proposition de organique relative à la
nomination des dirigeants de la SNCF il
s'agit de prévoir l'audition des deux
membres du directoire et du président du
conseil de surveillance de la SNCF
devant les commissions compétentes du
Parlement aux articles 10
11 et 16 les députés ont
considérablement clarifié et sécurisés
les opérations de transfert de propriété
entre les trois épiques à la fois sur
les aspects juridiques comptables et
fiscaux un travail technique nous avons
encore amélioré en commission
la question de la gestion des gardes
voyageurs a été soulevée par plusieurs
d'entre vous et députés ont prévu la
remise au Parlement d'un rapport du
Gouvernement sur le sujet qui devra
présenter l'impact d'un transfert des
garages SNCF réseau ou à des autorités
organisatrices de transport je suis
favorable à cette clause de revoyure
dans la mesure où il n'est pas possible
de traiter de façon satisfaisante dès
aujourd'hui ce sujet éminemment complexe
quant à l'article 11 bis il transfère à
SNCF réseau les terminaux de
marchandises appartenant à l'État et
géré par SNCF mobilité ainsi que
certaines installations de services
autre que les gars de voyageurs et les
centres d'entretien en commission nous
avons adopté une solution de compromis
en ce qui concerne la liste de référence
servant de base transfert en cas des
accords
le transfert sera automatiquement
constaté par la par le ministre sur la
base de la référence 2013 qui correspond
à 399 cours fret au lieu de la référence
2015 c'est-à-dire 171 notre principal
souci a été d'assuré la pérennité du
patrimoine ferroviaire il s'agit en
effet d'éviter toute reconversion
prématurée de bien potentiellement
stratégique ou qui pourrait servir à
d'autres opérateurs ferroviaires enfin
nous avons approuvé à l'article 6
l'ouverture salariés de RFF qui
remplissait les conditions d'embauche au
statut lors de leur recrutement un droit
d'opté pour le statut des cheminots à
l'article 14 le report au 1er juillet
2016 de l'échéance du 1er juillet 2015
pour l'aboutissement de la convention
collective afin de laisser davantage de
temps aux partenaires sociaux enfin
l'organisation
dans un délai d'un à compter de la
constitution du groupe public
ferroviaire d'élection professionnelle
anticipe au total
la commission du développement durable a
estimé que le projet de loi de réforme
ferroviaire fournit des outils
pertinents pour renforcer le système
ferroviaire et assurer son avenir nous
avons donc adopté ce texte ainsi
d'ailleurs que la proposition de loi
relative à la nomination des dirigeants
de la SNCF chers et chers collègues je
souhaite ardemment que notre assemblée
puis celle aussi manifester largement
son soutien à cette réforme je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur François
patriar rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances monsieur le
sénateur vous avez la parole
madame la Présidente je suis le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
ce qui évident qu'après l'excellent
rapport de michel Teston je
me contenterai de parler de ce qui a
impacté notre commission des finances
qui s'est saisi pour avis du projet de
loi portant réforme ferroviaire compte
tenues notamment de l'endettement
préoccupant du système ferroviaire qui
atteint on l'a déjà dit plus de 44
milliards d'euros dont 37 milliards
d'euros au titre de la phrase structure
cette dette mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre l'Insee a reconnu récemment
est en partie une dette publique nous
avons donc le devoir de la maîtriser de
la stabiliser et à terme de la réduire
c'est un des gens yeux de ce projet de
loi un parmi quelques autres non moins
important première étape indispensable
pour arriver à réduire cette dette
unification de l'infrastructure nous ne
pouvons plus nous contenter d'un système
existant dans lequel RFS SNCF se
coordonne mais n'arrive pas à trouver un
juste équilibre économique et financier
entre les objectifs contradictoires en
l'état actuel RFS est confronté à un
déficit annuel de 1,5 milliards d'euros
au titre de la maintenance du réseau
existant en outre ils doivent également
lever 1,5 milliards d'euros pour
financer le développement de quatre
lignes nouvelles que je ne cite pas ici
mais que vous avez tous en mémoire d'ici
10 ans
si nous vous ont être à la hauteur des
besoins de maintenance du réseau il
faudra investir 15 milliards d'euros
c'est l'ambition du grand plan de
modélisation du réseau dans ces
conditions comment nous satisfaire d'un
système d'un système sous optimal
l'unification de la phrases structure au
sein de SNCF réseau
constitue une évidence qui n'était
urgent de traduire dans les fêtes c'est
une amélioration fondamentale dans nos
espérons des gains de productivité de
mutualisation à hauteur de 900 millions
d'euros par an d'ici 10 ans de même
l'effort de l'État au titre de l'abandon
des dividendes et de l'impôt sur les
sociétés devraient soutenir SNCF réseau
à hauteur de 500 millions d'euros par an
ça c'est les efforts qu'on soit en
l'état cet équilibre financier repose
également sur la réalisation de la
plante performance du nouvel opérateur
SNCF mobilité pourra montant de 1
milliard d'euros
l'objectif que nous poursuivons c'est la
stabilisation de la dette d'ici 10 ans
c'est un objectif on le sait ambitieux
nul ne le conteste ni les établissements
ni le gouvernement il sera formalisé
dans les contrats notamment celui
conclut entre l'État et SNCF réseau dont
l'article 2 du projet de loi détaille
les clauses qui devront une figurer en
particulier la trajectoire financière à
10 ans projet de loi comprend deux
garde-fous pour éviter que SNCF réseau
ne s'écarte de la trajectoire financière
le premier garde-fou c'est l'autorité de
régulation des activités ferroviaires la
RAF ce régulateur veillera à la bonne
exécution du contrat de SNCF réseau il
émettra un avis sur le projet de budget
annuel du gestionnaire d'infrastructures
et l'incitera à le corriger s'ils
s'écarte de la trajectoire retenu
le secondaire de fou c'est la règle d'or
ou règle prudentielle pour le
financement des investissements de
développement c'est-à-dire l'ouverture
de nouvelles lignes qui évitera que SNCF
réseau sans dette de manière
inconsidérer si on doit ouvrir une
nouvelle ligne alors elle sera financée
par les demandeurs et non plus par le
gestionnaire de l'infrastructure tout
collectivité à l'état si elles veulent
des lignes d'un assumer le financement
le respect de cette règle d'or
d'ailleurs et lui-même surveillé par la
RF
l'objectif de stabilisation de la dette
bien selon qu'il s'agit est-il
réalisable les interlocuteurs que j'ai
rencontrés sont restés très prudents
cela cible visait d'ici 2025 certains
ont évoqué une stabilisation à hauteur
de 60 milliards d'euros à cette date
d'autres ne se sont pas avancés pour
d'autres encore l'état ne va pas assez
loin et les comptes ne seront pas
équilibrés à l'horizon 10 ans
il est vrai que des contraintes fortes
pèsent sur le secteur la commission des
finances a estimé que le scénario retenu
est effectivement soutenu à des alertes
le premier de ces aléas concerne les
ressources SNCF réseau les hausses de
péage d'infrastructure forte et
dernières années c'est 4 dernières
années seront limitées au moins jusqu'en
2018 SNCF réseau ne pourra donc pas
augmenter les recettes par un effet pris
quant au subventions publiques elles
seront au mieux maintenues mais il est
peu probable qu'elles augmentent
l'environnement économique sera par
conséquent déterminant pour assurer le
dynamisme des recettes de SNCF réseau le
second aléa auquel d'ailleurs son semis
d'ailleurs tous les emprunteurs et le
risque d'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
il ne vous a pas échappé
SNCF réseau devra donc engager des
efforts très importants sur la dépense
devant la commission Développement
Durable le président de RFS vous assurer
que 10% de gains de productivité est un
objectif atteignable il nous a dit nous
les avons sous le pied
écoutons-le et souhaitons-le nous lui
donnons donc cet engagement et nous
jugerons les résultats la commission des
finances est également demandé si nous
pouvions aller plus loin pour redonner
des marges de manœuvre à SNCF réseau je
veux bien évidemment parler de la
question de la reprise de tout ou partie
de la dette de l'État c'est une question
qui a été déjà posée à l'instant je veux
bien évidemment
sur ce domaine vous dire que cette idée
s'appuie notamment sur le fait que
l'INSEE en mai dernier à requalifier un
tiers de la dette de FF soit environ 10
milliards d'euros de dettes publiques il
s'agit peut-être de la fin d'une forme
d'hypocrisie consistant à nier le
caractère public de cette dette
néanmoins il faut aussi souligner que
l'INSEE a reconnu qu'un actif le réseau
était inscrit face à cette dette donc
des avoir en face des biens en
conséquence le stock de dette publique
celui qui est prise en compte pour le
calcul des ratios maastrichiens n'est
pas modifiée à l'inverse si l'état
venait à reprendre cette dette il
n'aurait plus d'actifs inscrits en
contrepartie et la dette net
augmenterait à du concurrence rendant
d'autant plus difficile l'ajustement de
nos comptes publics c'est pourquoi
on l'état actuel une telle reprise de
dette ne va pas paru souhaitable à la
commission des finances ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'elle ne doit pas être
envisagée à terme en toute état de cause
elle n'a pas non plus paru urgente parce
que RFF reste un emprunteur crédible les
investisseurs considèrent qu'il s'agit
d'une dette de l'État français la dette
est donc peu risqué à la différence des
taux d'intérêts entre RF et l'État et
minime
et la différence pardon d'intérêt de
taux d'intérêt entre FFR état et minime
on pourrait enfin s'interroger sur le
caractère vertueux d'une reprise de la
dette aujourd'hui le poids de la dette
est un aiguillon pour pousser SNCF
réseau à se transformer à se moderniser
elle conduira également à choisir avec
parcimonie les futurs projets de
développement je crois en effet que nous
devons nous interroger collectivement
sur les bons choix opérés pour notre
réseau de furet national en particulier
tous les rapports d'expertise soulignent
que le réseau est trop grand et qu'il
pourrait être réduit en vue de
rationaliser l'utilisation des moyens et
de maintenir et de le maintenir dans un
état de performance acceptable le
rapport de la commission mobilité 21
l'année dernière a souligné que le
devions faire des choix établir des
priorités dans la construction de
nouvelles infrastructures nous devons
faire les mêmes choix au regard du
réseau existant c'est de nouvelles
infrastructures sont nécessaires
d'autres ne le sont peut-être plus
la reprise de la dette ne doit pas
occulter ces questions fondamentales
ceci étant dit il y a également un
consensus pour dire que qu'une partie de
la dette SNCF réseau ne sera pas
amortissable par le système ferroviaire
à terme à terme l'Etat sera donc
probablement contraint de s'engager plus
et là pour se faire plusieurs
instruments à sa disposition la reprise
de dette mais aussi l'augmentation des
subventions le rapport demandé à
l'article de terre très bien tout à
l'heure expliqué notre ami michel Teston
du projet de loi doit nous permettre d'y
voir plus clair sur les modalités de
traitement de la dette historique
sous bénéfice de ces observations la
commission des finances a émis un avis
favorable aux articles dont elle s'est
saisi à savoir l'article premier
l'article 2tr 4 et 5 qui comportent
dispositions qui intéressent plus
directement l'équilibre financier de la
réforme mana la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président et
Monsieur rapporteur je vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur avant de
poursuivre la discussion générale je
donne la parole à Monsieur Jean-Jacques
Fillol pour une mise au point sur un
vote chaque collègue vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente oui je
voulais vous proposer au nom du groupe
socialiste une rectification au vote de
4 juillet au soir sur la PJL région en
effet messieurs Roland Courtot Marcel
Reynaud et Jean-Noël Gorini kerini vote
contre sur le vote final au lieu de ne
prennent pas par au vote je vous
remercie merci acte de votre mise au
point elle sera publiée au Journal
officiel et figuiera dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Louis pour le groupe ent
chers collègues vous avez la parole
je saurais peut-être un tout petit peu
plus loin
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
enfin pourrais-je dire enfin Monsieur le
Ministre le projet que vous nous
présentez et tissu d'une langue trop
lente maturation nous savons tous depuis
de très nombreuses années que le système
ferroviaire fonctionne de moins en moins
bien il était la fierté de la France il
en devient un souci
le constat est inquiétant c'est ainsi
par exemple que malgré les plans fêtent
qui se sont succédés cette activité à
diminuer notablement en France alors
qu'elle progressait dans plusieurs pays
européens
autre alerte dès 2005 vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre le rapport Rivier
suivi en 2012 par le rapport Putallaz et
la Cour des comptes nous confirmer que
le réseau classique était en bois des
fonds autre clignotant à l'orange qui
vire au rouge le matériel des trains
d'équilibre du territoire est obsolète
et fatigué vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure il ne correspond plus au service
qu'il doit à ses clientèle il est donc
urgent que les nouvelles rames arrivent
sur le terrain monsieur le ministre il
n'est pas jusqu'au TGV qui commence à
son tour à avoir des problèmes
d'équilibre financier sans oublier
l'accident dramatique de Brétigny
dans ce paysage qui s'assombrit d'année
à l'année seule l'action déterminée des
régions et leurs investissements massifs
ont apporté une bouffée d'oxygène au
ferroviaire avec à la clé une très forte
augmentation des passagers le rail
continue en effet à être un des moyens
de déplacement des plus modernes et
efficaces dans cette morosité ambiante
ce dernier exemple montre bien le rôle
irremplaçable du ferroviaire pour les
transports du quotidien monsieur le
ministre la transition énergétique et
l'aménagement du territoire
c'est ce constat aigre-doux cette
dégradation lente qui m'avait amené dès
octobre 2010 à réclamé à mon
gouvernement du haut de cette tribune un
Grenelle du ferroviaire
il m'a fallu plus de
pour l'obtenir à travers les assises du
ferroviaire aujourd'hui après des années
de tergiversation vous nous présentez
l'aboutissement de ces discussions et
réflexions dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi
portant réforme ferroviaire mon analyse
de ce texte me conduit un triple constat
en premier lieu je ne peux que me
féliciter que les fonctions de
gestionnaire d'infrastructures du réseau
terrain national aujourd'hui répartis
entre RFM SNCF Infra et la DCF soit
unifiée
cette mesure était attendue et a fait
l'unanimité auprès de tous les acteurs
elle permettra sans aucun doute en
meilleure fonctionnement du système et
une plus grande sécurité
vous redonnez à l'état grâce à ce projet
de loi un rôle d'État stratège bienvenue
pour fixer les priorités et la cohérence
du système ferroviaire
j'ai bien noté en ce sens que l'État
assurerait également le pilotage de la
filière industrielle ferroviaire dont
vous le savez monsieur le ministre le
plan de charge est en diminution
dramatique à court terme de même à
travers le schéma national des services
de transport les orientations de l'État
pourront s'afficher clairement cette
démarche s'accompagne par ailleurs d'une
mobilisation positive du Parlement qui
aura à connaître les dossiers les plus
importants du système ferroviaire mais a
priori à ma surprise sans vote j'ai donc
proposé en commission d'aller plus loin
mais de voter une grande loi de
programmation ferroviaire
je pense que le Parlement doit en
débattre librement et s'engager par un
vote ainsi nous pourrons associer toute
la nation à la définition des objectifs
que doit atteindre le système
ferroviaire
de même après un impair
incompréhensible dans le texte initial
vous avez accepté la vie conforme de la
RAF et vous avez même augmenté fort
justement grâce à l'Assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs ces possibilités
d'intervention dans le cadre que vous
avez choisi d'une entreprise intégrée
verticalement un régulateur fort est
absolument indispensable et j'en suis
d'accord avec le rapporteur
enfin je note avec satisfaction que ce
texte devrait permettre de définir des
objectifs de performance et de
productivité tout en maîtrisant les
dépenses à travers une règle d'or mais
j'ai également entendu le rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des finances
qui parlait d'ores et le cas de dire en
disant que si tout va bien nous ne
serons qu'à 60 milliards de dettes en
2025 c'est donc un vrai problème ces
éléments positifs étant acté je fais
cependant un deuxième constat qui lui
m'interpelle quant à la lisibilité du
système
sa complexité telle qu'elle apparaît à
travers ce projet de loi ne plonge dans
un océan de perplexité un effet en
dehors des spécialistes la plupart des
interlocuteurs que j'ai rencontrées ont
eu des difficultés à comprendre qui
faisait quoi au départ nous avons un
EPIC mais avec deux épites filles donc
une dispose d'une entité autonome gains
et connexion mais ces établissements
sont alors tour accompagnés par une
véritable nébuleuse à travers
l'existence d'un conseil de surveillance
lui-même ayant un rôle différent du Haut
Comité du système de transport
ferroviaire qui ne recouvre pas les
missions du comité des opérateurs de
réseau dont le rôle est bien sûr
différent de l'Autorité de régulation
des activités ferroviaires qui ne doit
pas se confondre avec l'établissement
public de sécurité ferroviaire sans
monsieur le ministre la commission des
sanctions la commission de déontologie
et le Haut Comité à la qualité de
service dans les transports qui tousse
concours à des degrés divers au
fonctionnement du système ferroviaire
français dans le système précédent après
des années on ne savait toujours pas à
qui appartenait les quais et à qui
appartenait les bordures de quai le
système actuel n'est malheureusement pas
plus lisible cette organisation qui
ressemble fort à une usine à gaz est
difficilement compréhensible pour le
commun des mortels
malheureusement monsieur le ministre je
fais un troisième constat qui lui est
beaucoup plus gras en effet il y a toute
une série de points sur lesquels je ne
partage pas votre philosophie et votre
vision de l'avenir je me situe même à
l'opposé de votre démarche politique et
vous n'en serez pas étonné
j'en veux pour preuve plusieurs éléments
avec deux séries de réactions de plus en
plus négatives de ma part
une première série de désaccords porte
notamment sur trois points
et oui
et oui oui et bah oui mais je suis assez
sénateur libre et honnête je dis ce que
je pense et donc j'annonce j'annonce
toute une série de choses que je trouve
positives et je dis aussi ce qui ne me
paraît pas positif voilà et c'est
l'honneur de la Haute Assemblée de
pouvoir parler ainsi sur le commissaire
du Gouvernement auprès de la race
l'utilité de ce dernier m'échappe en
effet le gouvernement peut très bien
transmettre ses analyses directement à
la RAF sans avoir besoin d'un
commissaire qui fait penser plutôt un
commissaire politique nous nous sentons
d'autant plus en droit nous nous sentons
monsieur le ministre à droite nous nous
sentons d'autant plus en droit de faire
cette remarque que dans le cadre de
l'ARCEP de l'Autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes en 2011 cette même manique
gouvernementale avait été retoquée par
la Commission européenne
concernant deuxième point concernant
d'autre part la gestion des gardes le
rapport du 22 avril 2013 de Jacques
oxiet bien connu sur tous ces bancs à
gauche avait préconisé de regrouper au
sein de SNCF réseau l'ensemble du
patrimoine foncier ferroviaire cela
paraissait on ne peut plus logique dans
le même sens l'Autorité de la
concurrence dans son avis du 4 octobre
2013 juge elle aussi nécessaire que soit
garantie la neutralité concurrentielle
des gares de voyageurs pour dit-elle ne
pas entraver un développement affectif
de la concurrence cet avis ne souffre
pas d'interprétation il est très clair
et je ne peux donc monsieur le ministre
que regretter votre position enfin
concernant les matériels roulants
régionaux je suis monsieur le ministre
là encore en total opposition avec votre
article 5 bis du projet de loi en effet
il est incompréhensible pour tout être
normalement constitué que les régions
qui ont financé avec les deux derniers
publics des contribuables locaux
l'intégralité des rames n'en soit pas
propriétaire et j'avoue que dans le
cadre de la commission du développement
durable grâce au président et à son
rapporteur nous avançons nous cheminons
vers peut-être une solution qui nous
paraissait plus logique je me pose la
question de savoir Monsieur le Ministre
pourquoi vous avez inscrit cette mesure
aussi étrange qui logique mais
mais s'il n'y avait que ces remarques
hélas trois fois hélas il y a encore
plus gras il s'agit à mes yeux de trois
points fondamentaux qui ne sont pas
traités au mieux tout juste abordé le
premier point porte sur la dette de la
vie générale la situation est gravissime
aujourd'hui elle explose à plus de 40
milliards d'euros elle entraîne une
charge financière de près de 1 milliards
et demi ce problème essentiel dans le
cadre d'une vraie réforme ferroviaire ne
fait l'objet que d'approche qui ne sont
pas à la hauteur du problème il est
significatif que le gouvernement n'est
prévu chers collègues n'est prévu qu'un
simple rapport sur les solutions qui
pourraient aux conditionner être mise en
œuvre et ceci dans deux ans
cette situation est en sienne et chaque
année un peu plus alarmante votre
proposition à la différence des mesures
drastiques et douloureuses compris les
Allemands en leur temps consiste à
repousser à plus tard l'assainissement
des comptes
c'est d'autant plus incompréhensible que
ressent Lindsay est la Cour des comptes
ont confirmé qu'il était dès aujourd'hui
possible de transférer plus de 10
milliards à l'état ce qui permettrait en
deux ans chers collègues de soulager le
système ferroviaire d'un milliard
d'euros de charge de la dette alors
qu'il y a le feu à la maison on regarde
d'ailleurs et ce problème gravissime
plombe l'ensemble du système ferroviaire
et je ne reviendrai pas sur la vie de la
commission des finances la commission
numéro 3 des assises auxquelles je vous
renvoie a d'ailleurs confirmé cette
analyse en son temps en précisant que la
seule la seule clé de désendettement du
secteur était la résorption du déficit
structurel nous en sommes loin
ce qui nous amène un deuxième fouet
fondamental de votre réforme qui est
l'absence je dis bien l'absence
d'ouverture à la concurrence
en 2009 chers collègues mon premier
amendement sénatorial déposé à la haute
assemblée était consacrée à une
ouverture maîtrisée à la concurrence
je crois profondément quant à moi que ce
mécanisme s'avérerait extrêmement
bénéfique pour la SNCF et pour les
usagers mais au lieu d'aborder
franchement cette question et de passer
à l'offensive nos reculons à nouveau en
effet un effet la commission numéro 1
des Assises du ferroviaire présidé par
Monsieur Gilles Savary qui n'était pas
encore rapporteur à l'Assemblée
nationale avait déclaré en 2011 il y a
quatre ans déjà que le principe d'une
ouverture à la concurrence était actée
pour les autorités organisatrices qui le
souhaiteraient
malheureusement en 2014 une année
toujours rien
bien au contraire le texte n'en parle
même pas à l'image de l'urbain la
concurrence instaurée je vous le
rappelle par Michel Sapin en personne
permet au pourtant le développement et
permettrait pourtant le développement de
l'emploi au sein de la SNCF d'augmenter
l'offre pour les usagers et en fait de
réaliser des économies substantielles de
l'ordre de 15 à 20% ce qui est
considérable les 870 millions d'euros
annuels ainsi économiser permettrait
soit des investissements supplémentaires
soit de diminuer la charge financière
des collectivités et donc des
contribuables c'est d'autant plus
regrettable que la SNCF libérait à
l'international et tout à fait capable
de conquérir vous l'avez dit sans aucun
dumping social départ de marché et de
promouvoir avec une grande efficacité la
marque France
enfin le dernier point qui s'inscrit
dans la logique qui est la vôtre et que
je récuse totalement va entraîner le
verrouillage complet du système
ferroviaire national à travers le
caractère indissociable et solidaire des
trois entités à travers la création d'un
seul comité central du groupe public à
travers un délégué syndical central à
travers toutes ces dispositions de
dernière minute qui fleuront le
centralisme démocratique nous en
revenons à la SNCF de grand-papa c'est
un retour en arrière complet si l'on
ajoute l'intangibilité des statues et
leur inadaptation en monde qui évolue si
l'on ajoute que le décrit socle fera
disparaître le peu de concurrence qui
existait on aboutit encore une fois au
syndrome de la ligne Maginot rester
autant sur la défensive s'enfermer sur
les droits acquis en bref ne pas bouger
ne pas évoluer entraînera
malheureusement un affaiblissement du
système ferroviaire susceptible à terme
de mettre en cause son existence même
votre modèle pour reprendre votre terme
monsieur le ministre n'est pas notre
modèle le cadre dramatique de la SNCM
devrait pourtant nous alerter sur la
nécessité pour la France de développer
des entreprises compétitives aptes à
gagner la bataille de l'emploi plutôt
qu'à se recroqueviller sur elle-même en
définitive monsieur le ministre votre
projet de loi se limite à une réforme
institutionnelle il ne touche pas à une
traite donc pas au fond les problèmes
principaux j'insiste qui grève l'avenir
du rail comme par exemple n'est pas
raison mais après l'exemple allemand je
peux aussi prendre l'exemple italien
actuel où le président du Conseil Matteo
Renzi lance une réforme structurelle par
mois c'est l'opposé de cette approche
étriquée de ce manque de vision
cette réforme n'engage pas les réformes
de structure madame la Présidente
absolument indispensable elle n'est pas
la loi fondatrice du ferroviaire attendu
depuis 2011 c'est donc une mini réforme
suivie à l'Assemblée nationale d'une
contre-réforme et cet exemple nous amène
un texte baroque qui n'est absolument
pas à la hauteur des enjeux en
conséquence le groupe
UMP votera contre ce projet de l’eau
merci monsieur le sénateur
la parole est à Monsieur Vincent capo
canelas pour le groupe
udi
UC
sur le sénateur vous seul avez la parole
et vos collègues nous écoutent madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
de développement durable messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
système ferroviaire français est
constitutif de notre identité il fait je
ne parle pas au passé la fierté de notre
pays malgré les difficultés la fierté
des cheminots d'abord fierté légitime et
celle de nos compatriotes nous aimons
les chemins de fer pour autant nous
devons donner un nouveau départ au
modèle ferroviaire français ce modèle
ferroviaire c'est une vision de la
France de la mobilité des territoires on
sait que ce qu'on vient cela compte en
particulier ici au Sénat
la SNCF dans l'histoire nous a montré
combien elle savait être au rendez-vous
nous devons nous aussi être rendez vous
pour franchir une étape indispensable au
renouveau du chemin de fer français nous
mesurons l'enjeu permettre au système
ferroviaire français d'assurer son
avenir l'enjeu c'est à partir de cette
histoire de cette tradition française
avec les cheminots de redonner au
système ferroviaire français un cadre
clair qui lui permet de se développer
pour perpétuer cette tradition la
renouveler il faut changer car la
situation actuelle ne peut durer changer
car les cheminots eux-mêmes appellent à
plus d'efficacité il faut redonner au
système ferroviaire français une
ambition non pas qu'il en manque
aujourd'hui mais la question posée est
celle des moyens je crois que le système
ferroviaire français est un tournant ce
moment est sans doute un moment clé il
faut changer certes changer pour mieux
de ferroviaire
au départ il y a plusieurs constats la
complexité du système actuel le besoin
de modernisation du réseau l'impasse
financière qui malheureusement va
croissant
une question aussi celle de la
hiérarchisation des priorités quel
réseau comment l'entretenir face à ces
constats notre ambition est de
renouveler le système ferroviaire
français
il est bon que l'État se dot enfin d'une
stratégie en matière ferroviaire il est
inutile de développer plus longuement
les mots de notre système car cela était
10 par de nombreux orateurs et encore à
l'instant par Louis la spirale de
l'endettement un réseau vieillissant et
dégradé dans de multiples rapports ont
fait le constat et bien évidemment nous
avons une pensée pour les victimes de
l'accident de Brétigny au moment où le
rapport vient d'être publié un système
pas assez compétitif aussi c'est une
réalité qu'il faut voir en face avec un
coût supérieur de 30% à celui de nos
voisins et aujourd'hui concurrencé par
d'autres modes de transport
le projet de loi élaboré par le
gouvernement avec les acteurs du
ferroviaire je le dis dans cet ordre
sans malice croyant ne pas le tromper ce
projet de loi gouvernemental donc
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la réflexion
lancée par le précédent gouvernement au
travers des acides du ferroviaire il y a
une forme de continuité au moins dans
l'intention de départ
l'équation départ est simple
les intentions étaient claires
reconstituer un gestionnaire unifié
l'infrastructure cela faisait fait
toujours consensus
mais aussi adapter le système
ferroviaire français aux exigences
d'aujourd'hui et ça c'est plus
douloureux
ça a été au départ ça le sera toujours
et les grèves récentes ont montré
l'inquiétude et cheminots et la
difficulté la tâche
parmi les exigences d'aujourd'hui
auxquelles il faut savoir s'adapter je
voudrais citer cinq axes de travail la
qualité de service aux voyageurs nous la
devons aux usagers elle existe elle doit
s'améliorer pour plus de régularité la
sécurité chacun le mesure avec force
évidemment à quelques jours
l'anniversaire de la catastrophe de
Brétigny parce qu'il faut voir les
choses en face aussi le coût du système
ferroviaire aujourd'hui trop élevé est
aussi une exigence qu'il faut relever la
nécessaire inclusion des chemins de fer
dans une stratégie globale de mobilité
avec la concurrence et la
complémentarité des autres modes de
transport s'impose également à nous
enfin la concurrence motabou mais
réalité de demain à laquelle nous
devrons nous conforter pour en ressortir
vainqueur doit être regardé en face ni à
la perspective n'est pas la solution
face à ces différents enjeux le projet
de loi soumis à la Haute Assemblée
souffre selon nous de trois
insuffisances en premier lieu le système
mis en place est complexe avec trois
épis un briquet le recompatibilité que
vous revendiquez restera à confirmer
avec de nouvelles commissions et le
nouveau Parlement européen attention à
l'adoption du quatrième paquet quelques
points majeurs restent à signaler
l'accès équitable réseau le rôle du
régulateur la place prépondérante de
l'opérateur historique l'endoganie du
système dans la version initiale du
texte rester des questions assez
maltraitées et demeure encore à
améliorer en second lieu votre réforme
paraît insuffisamment financé et ne
traite pas assez de la dette ferroviaire
qui atteint 44 milliards d'euros qui
progressent d'un milliards 5 par an
devrait être atteindre 60 milliards dans
quelques années et 70 milliards en 2025
une réforme sans la dette est-ce une
réforme enfin le projet de loi se
concentrant essentiellement sur les
questions de gouvernance il contourne la
question principale de la modernisation
du système ferroviaire de l'amélioration
de la qualité de service de la
productivité et d'adaptation à la
concurrence cette réalité est pourtant
devant nous cela étant dit le travail de
l'Assemblée nationale a permis des
avancer un premier pas a été fait en
direction des régions pas trop timide
avec plus de transparence des comptes
une liberté tarifaire à peine esquisser
la question du matériel roulant aborder
un parfaitement mais abordé le chef de
fila pour les gardes latéraires
régionales je crois que les régions
seront les moteurs de la rénovation du
système elles n'en ont pas encore les
moyens un premier pas a été fait en leur
direction ce pas et selon nous beaucoup
trop timide la seule avancée notable
concerne un transparence et compte des
in TER que réclament légitimement les
régions le chef de fila qui leur a été
reconnu uniquement pour les gardes
intérêts régionales et la question du
matériel roulant ne me paraît pas
suffisamment bien réglé
des améliorations ont été apportées sur
la gouvernance et les pouvoirs de la RAF
le régulateur ce point mérite lui aussi
d'être renforcé nous estimons que ces
améliorations sont encore insuffisantes
et qu'il faut encore renforcer
l'étanchéité entre les différents épices
et garantir l'indépendance de l'autorité
de régulation afin de garantir la donc
d'un non discrimination entre opérateur
s'agissons de la dette la règle
prudentielle a été seulement esquissé et
en aucun cas les économies d'échelle
attendu ne permettront de réduire le
stock de dette ce point est majeur les
promesses économies ne sont pas des
économies et il en est ici que du budget
de l'État malheureusement le cadre
social a été complété certes
pour rassurer les cheminots qui doivent
accompagner la réforme et en être acteur
être des véritables acteurs du
changement ces avancées issus de
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale on
pourrait les résumer en deux temps une
part de réalisme les régions la RAF il
s'agit de premier pas à conforter une
part de dialogue social renforcé
gageons que le cadre social amélioré
sera demain un élément positif et pas un
élément de blocage du moins
souhaitons-le cette réforme peut encore
être améliorée il y a et j'ai entendu le
vinaigre à l'instant deux attitudes
possibles
condamner la réforme mais n'est-ce pas
condamner système ferroviaire a-t-on le
temps ou bien faire le pari du
pragmatisme et construire pas à pas mais
en accélérant donc choisir d'améliorer
le texte nous choisirions volontiers le
pragmatisme s'il était réciproque je
crois que faire de ce sujet un combat
idéologique ce ne serait pas un service
à rendre système ferroviaire il y a des
réalités et des urgences
la réforme telle qu'elle est proposée
aujourd'hui malgré les travaux de la
commission et je salue le président Val
le rapporteur michel Teston
cette réforme et largement imparfaite
notre volonté de regarder comment
l'approfondir en allant plus loin dans
l'adaptation au quatrième pack et
ferroviaire en préparant progressivement
l'ouverture à la concurrence ici il me
faut m'adresser à vous monsieur le
ministre il y a une ambiguïté dans votre
réforme et vous devez la levée soit
c'est la politique de l'autruche et nous
connaîtrons pour le trafic voyageur ce
que nous avons connu pour le fret soit
c'est un pas pour adapter réellement le
système ferroviaire en réalité
d'aujourd'hui
si comme je le souhaite la deuxième
hypothèse et la bonne vous devez
accepter ici de faire bouger les
curseurs j'entends bien que le cadre
social doit être respecté
je comprends que l'architecture
institutionnelle du projet peut
difficilement à ce stade évoluer
considérablement mais je dois ici
rappeler que autant nous sommes d'accord
avec la constitution d'un gestionnaire
d'infrastructures unifiée
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des conclusions
des acides du ferroviaires
et on peut estimer ici que la réforme de
97 a montré ses limites
mais autant nous sommes d'accord avec le
g.i autant le pôle public intégré nous
laisse dubitatif
mais sur les autres points sur
l'économie
sur le régulateur sur la dette sur le
pouvoir des régions il faut je crois
savoir aller plus loin franchir le pas
qui fera cette réforme une adaptation
nécessaire et utile plutôt qu'un élément
qui est destiné à éviter de voir les
réalités notre guide dans la discussion
des articles et des amendements sera
simples nous aborderons sur des points
précis certains d'ailleurs ont été
évoqués par Louis parce que nous
avons un certain nombre d'axes
évidemment commun nous poursuivrons
plusieurs objectifs je voudrais en
rappeler 5 rapidement
le premier c'est d'inscrire la
stabilisation voir la diminution de la
dette comme priorité de cette réforme
ferroviaire encore une fois une réforme
sans la dette s'est repoussée à demain
le plus important deuxième objectif
c'est de préparer
le système ferroviaire au quatrième
paquet et à l'ouverture à la concurrence
en permettant par exemple aux régions
d'expérimenter les délégations de
services publics il peut y avoir
plusieurs façons d'y arriver mais
l'intention le réalisme doit être là le
troisième objectif doit être de
renforcer l'indépendance des
établissements publics au sein du pôle
unifié que vous avez choisi afin de
rendre le projet de loi pleinement
compatible avec les règles européennes
c'est aussi d'ailleurs nécessaire pour
garantir un accès équitable au réseau
notre quatrième objectif en concurrence
avec le précédent c'est bien sûr de
renforcer encore les pouvoirs de la RAF
comme véritable autorité de régulation
indépendante et le vinaigre a évoqué
tout à l'heure la question du
commissaire du gouvernement c'est
d'autant plus nécessaire que votre
système peut parfois être considéré
comme ambigu donc remettons de la clarté
enfin nous voulons c'est le cinquième
objectif rendre le train plus compétitif
et plus attractif cela veut dire
améliorer la pro activité du système la
qualité du service rendu aux usagers
revenir à des prix concurrentiels aussi
quand même quand on est sur Internet et
qu'on regarde les prix on se désespère
parfois tout cela appelle une volonté
claire sur les points que je viens
d'énumérer je veux dire que la réponse
du gouvernement sera déterminante pour
que nous considérions notre vote nous
avons déposé des amendements et nous
aurons l'occasion d'approfondir la
discussion votre projet de départ
n'est pas le nôtre monsieur le ministre
vous le savez l'assemblée l'améliorer il
reste du chemin à faire
sur le texte initial vous avions de
grandes réserves une partie a été levée
nous mesurons l'enjeu pour le système
ferroviaire et les cheminots l'enjeu
c'est de s'adapter et de se redonner des
moyens d'être compétitifs
repousser la mise en concurrence sans
s'y préparer n'est pas la solution au
contraire c'est l'assurance de réveil
douloureux ce texte s'il est adopté par
le Sénat ce qui ne me paraît pas acquis
à cette heure ne règlera pas tout il
faudra demain encore aller plus loin
dans l'expérimentation des délégations
de service public gageons que les
régions elles-mêmes y viendront
après tout le droit européen existe il
faudra aussi à court terme réussir le
quatrième paquet ferroviaire avec un
Parlement européen et une commission
renouvelée ce ne sera pas forcément le
plus facile la France a trop souvent
l'image d'un pays qui ne sait pas se
réformer si cette réforme devra bien sûr
être suivie d'autres dans ce domaine
précis elle peut malgré tout contribuer
à améliorer la situation du chemin de
fer français la discussion vaut en tout
cas d'être engagée et c'est dans cet
esprit que nous examinerons ce texte
je terminerai en évoquant bien sûr les
attentes des voyageurs il est des
secteurs et l'Île-de-France en étant
vous le savez monsieur ministre ou
l'exaspération des voyageurs est à son
comble hier encore ce ministre le RER B
ici à la station Luxembourg était
bloquée à 20h en plein conseil municipal
j'attendais encore un surnom de mes élus
qui était là encore dans le RER il faut
répondre à cette attente je cite la
ligne que je connais le mieux mais il en
est d'autres qui souffrent tout autant
je veux dire aussi que les annonces du
procureur d'Evry forcément légitime
quant à l'état devait sucer du réseau en
particulier en garde Noisy-le-Sec
interroge et interpelle nos concitoyens
il faut monsieur ministre rassurer sur
les moyens mis en œuvre car les usagers
et le maire de Noisy-le-Sec en
particulier sont légitimement inquiets
du constat qui a été livré à l'opinion
tout cela nous rappelle si besoin que la
finalité du réseau comme du transporteur
c'est bien d'être au service du public
pour transporter chacun des usagers en
cela le système ferroviaire répond à une
obligation de service public et
d'égalité c'est un beau défi qui nous
faut relever aujourd'hui encore alors je
sais la passion du ferroviaire et le
talent de notre rapporteur michel Teston
je sais Monsieur ministre votre écoute
du Parlement et je veux dire que dans la
discussion qui s'engage
on aura quelques idées simples en tête
cette réforme était
assez mal engagée
peut-être sur la mauvaise voie à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a peut-être
validé avec la grève vous avez réussi à
ce qu'il en soit rien après son passage
à l'assemblée a été régulier dans un
sens plus favorable espérons qu'avec son
examen au Sénat elle sera enfin sur de
bons rails il n'appartient qu'à vous
monsieur le ministre d'orienter ce
projet de loi dans le bon sens et de
faire arriver cette réforme hacker et à
temps je vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole est
maintenant à Madame Mireille Church pour
le groupe CRC
chers collègues vous avez la parole
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
maintenant inadapté délabrement jamais
vu les mots du procureur en charge de
l'accident de brequis sont durs très dur
à entendre pour nous qui aimons le
chemin de fer ils font cependant écho à
ceux des cheminots qui depuis plusieurs
années nous alerte sur la dégradation du
service public ferroviaire ainsi que du
constat unanimement partagé des Assises
du ferroviaire cela vient s’ajouter
aussi à la charge médiatique sur les
rames de TER de TER inadaptées à la
largeur des quais et renforce le
sentiment de gâchis et d'insécurité des
usagers
la SNCF est une entreprise publique de
services publics caractérisé par
certaines valeurs qui s'immensent le
corps social et le territoire national
malheureusement les choix des
gouvernements successifs et de la
Direction ont tendu à l'assimiler à une
entreprise comme une autre le
cloisonnement des métiers et des
personnels ainsi que le recours massif à
la sous-traitance des activités
essentielles mais à mal la
complémentarité et les savoirs multiples
apportant son lot d'inquiétude de
souffrance et de dysfonctionnement
pour notre part dans une démarche
constante et cohérente nous n'avons
jamais cessé de pointer les lacunes de
la réforme de 97 le poids des intérêts
divergents de RFS et SNCF la perte
d'énergie dans la gestion des relations
entre deux entreprises publiques qui
devaient logiquement travailler ensemble
et la remise en cause de la légitimité
des cheminots que ce soit dans notre
proposition de loi permettant la relance
du secteur public ferroviaire de mai
2012 ou encore notre proposition de
résolution tendant la maîtrise publique
du système ferroviaire national de
juillet 2013 sans parler de notre
résolution demandant une évaluation de
la libéralisation du secteur nous avons
été attentifs aux préoccupations des
acteurs de terrain et appelé de nos vœux
une réforme du système ferroviaire c'est
pourquoi nous saluons monsieur le
ministre vos efforts pour que ce texte
soit inscrit à l'ordre du jour
nous assemblées cela d'autant plus
qu'une course de vitesse est engagée
avec la Commission européenne toutefois
le quatrième paquet ferroviaire vous
l'avez rappelé n'est pas encore voté et
la Commission européenne a déjà dû
reculer à cet égard rappelons que le
droit positif impose seulement une
séparation des fonctions essentielles la
définition des péages et la répartition
des sillons de plus les états est donc
les gouvernements ne sont pas étrangers
à la production législative européenne
et ils ont une marge de manœuvre dans la
transposition des directives c'est
pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre n'utilisez
pas l'argument de l'euro compatibilité
ou de la concurrence comme un dépassable
il ne peut pas y avoir de double
discours en National et l'autre européen
votre gouvernement monsieur le ministre
veut je lui ai entendu de la part du
Premier ministre un gouvernement de
combat
et la France vous l'avez rappelé je
reprends vos mots est une grande nation
ferroviaire et européenne qui a un poids
certain dans les négociations
européennes ce projet de loi est donc
une formidable opportunité pour faire
valoir les exigences de la France dans
le domaine ferroviaire
dès lors pardon ne reproduisons pas les
erreurs passées sous couvert d'un
discours d'urgence ou de contraintes
réelles et où imaginaires c'est pourquoi
nous porterons à travers nos amendements
la défense d'un modèle unifié autour de
l'entreprise publique SNCF car il a fait
ses preuves par le passé et nous pensons
qu'il est seul à même de répondre au
défi du futur aux exigences d'un service
public ferroviaire fiable et performant
au service des usagers et des
territoires un service public qui ne
soit pas comme cela transparer en
filigranes dans ce projet de loi
exclusivement orientée vers la gestion
de l'infrastructure le service public
que nous défendons englobe l'offre de
services la gestion et le déploiement
des réseaux mais aussi la gestion des
gares et du patrimoine ferroviaire
s'il est impératif de mettre un terme à
l'absence de vision cohérente à long
terme du système ferroviaire la question
de son financement ne peut être minorée
et reporté dans le temps à sa création
RFS à hérité de la dette SNCF au départ
20 milliards d'euros qui devient
aujourd'hui comme la rappeler le
rapporteur colossal qui n'apparaît plus
comme de la dette publique pourtant le
désencatement de la SNCF aurait pu être
obtenu par le transfert d'une partie de
ces dettes de l'État ce que la directive
de 91 autorisée d'ailleurs dans la
plupart des autres pays européens l'État
a ainsi repris une grande partie des
dettes de l'opérateur ferroviaire
historiques comme en Allemagne par
exemple pourtant force est de constater
que l'État n'a toujours pas l'intention
de désencer le système ferroviaire ce
projet à notre avis n'apporte pas de
réponse satisfaisante à cette question
pourtant cruciale
la seule perspective de ce projet de loi
sur le financement du système réside
dans ce que vous appelez des gains de
performance dans les organisations et
les modes de travail dans l'ensemble du
groupe et
l'optimisation de l'offre ferroviaire
vous comprendrez monsieur le ministre au
vu de l'actualité cela crée un certain
malaise car c'est cette logique
d'abaissement des coûts de suppression
d'emplois d'abaissement de la qualité
des formations dispensées de réduction
des moyens financiers et matériels qui
dégradent les conditions de travail des
cheminots et la qualité du service
public SNCF rendu aux usagers et à la
nation cette logique qui encourage un
recours toujours plus important à la
sous-traitance pour réaliser la
maintenance verra peut-être se
multiplier la catastrophe comme celle de
Brétigny car selon les chiffres annoncés
lors des débats l'Assemblée nationale
pour trouver 250 millions d'euros annuel
il faudrait réduire les effectifs de
4330 personnes par an en 5 ans ce serait
donc plus de 20
000 salariés en moins
reconnaissons monsieur le ministre les
craintes des cheminots ne sont pas
dénuées de fondement
de plus quand vous parlez de
l'optimisation de l'offre ferroviaire
ainsi que la règle prudentielle il
prévoit une hiérarchisation des
investissements en faveur des projets
présentant le meilleur retour
d'investissement ce qui à terme se
traduira inévitablement par des
fermetures de lignes en effet le projet
prévoit un système de priorisation des
projets ferroviaires c'est-à-dire que
les travaux nécessaires à la
régénération du réseau ne serait
effectuée que lorsqu'ils sont jugés
utiles et que les finances le permettent
c'est-à-dire pour certaines de ces
lignes jamais c'est donc le passage de
la recherche d'une sécurité maximale un
risque
calculé il faudra expliquer cela à nos
concitoyens monsieur le ministre vous
rayez au fond d'un trait de plumes les
engagements de la commission mobilité 21
d'autre part la gestion en temps réel du
trafic relève complètement de
l'opérationnel de l'exploitation
ferroviaire est fait partie des
fondements de la sécurité de la qualité
des services ferroviaires effectifs
alors que la gestion de l'infrastructure
au sens propre a lieu en amont en temps
différé où est donc dans votre projet la
construction d'une synergie en temps
réel des équipes de terrain par exemple
aiguillages et manœuvre de train sur ce
terrain monsieur le ministre votre
réforme ne répond pas aux attentes des
cheminots en termes d'efficacité
à cet égard le nouveau rôle de gendarme
financier d'évolue à la RAF nous
interroge nous avons toujours contester
vous le savez ce type de structure dont
les missions non à notre avis rien à
voir avec le service public puisque
l'unique objectif poursuivi est de faire
de la place aux nouveaux entrants et
donc d'assurer la concurrence nous
portons l'idée que la régulation du
système ferroviaire régulation oui du
système ferroviaire doit être la mission
de l'État plutôt que d'une structure
soi-disant indépendante est loin de la
notion de service public
euros compatibilité ouverture à la
concurrence pérennité de la réforme mais
aussi unicité du système sont les termes
que vous utilisez pour décrire votre
réforme vous nous dites efficacité du
système ainsi pour remédier à
l'éclatement du passé il faudrait la
création de nouvelles entités vous en
avez créé trois en SNCF SNCF réseau et
SNCF mobilité
par une
mathématique pardon opaque vous affirmez
monsieur le ministre que 3 serait plus
performant que deux et que 3 serait
encore plus performant que 1 pourtant
les directives européennes imposent
absolument pas la mise en place de trois
épices distinctes elle n'exige de
séparation organique que pour les
fonctions essentielles pourquoi ne pas
avoir simplement externaliser ses
fonctions auprès de la DG ITM et
reconstruit un groupe public ferroviaire
autour d'un seul épique si l'objectif
est la rationalisation et l'efficacité
du système pourquoi n'avoir pas retenu
cette solution de bon sens au lieu de
multiplier les structures et compétences
de coordination
d'arbitrage de consultation
d'autant qu'il y a toujours un président
de SNCF SNCF réseau un président de SNCF
mobilité la complexité est loin à notre
avis d'avoir disparu aru
vous nous dites que cette réforme
apportera des économies pouvez-vous être
plus précis au vu de l'empilement de
toutes ces nouvelles structures et
instances diverses et variées vous nous
dites pérennité de la réforme ce choix
des trois épiques nous interroge en
effet et vous le savez les pics est une
forme juridique aujourd'hui menacée la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne a
une suspicion sur le régime juridique
des épiques à cet égard l'exemple de la
Poste est éclairant et nous nous sommes
battus à gauche contre le changement de
statut de La Poste à l'époque il ne
faudrait donc qu'un pas pour que la Cour
de justice de l'Union européenne juge
tout simplement les épis comme
incompatibles avec le marché intérieur
en outre par le passé la séparation
filiale de différentes activités a été
le plus sur chemin vers leur
privatisation c'est pourquoi le schéma
proposé n'emporte pas notre conviction
surtout au vu des transferts d'actifs
organisés dans les articles 10 et
suivant du projet de loi qui tout en
renforçant SNCF réseau a pu en quelque
sorte les contes de SNCF mobilité vous
nous dites unicité du système et
simplification depuis plusieurs années
les régions sont désireuses d'affirmer
le rôle d'autorité organisatrice de
transport de plaine exercices auxquelles
ne sont pas si le texte initial
prévoyait un léger renforcement des
régions le passage à l'Assemblée
nationale tente à une véritable
régionalisation de notre système
ferroviaire certes les députés ont
refusé de reconnaître aux régions les
prérogatives d'autorité organisatrice de
plein exercice toutefois il appartiendra
aux régions de définir la politique
tarifaire des services d'intérêt
régional elles pourront devenir
propriétaire et gestionnaires
d'infrastructures compétences qu'elle
sous traiteront nous sommes loin de
l'unité du réseau pire à notre avis
c'est un éclatement du réseau dont il
s'agirait
avec cette réforme le risque est grand
que subsiste les stratégies concurrentes
des différents acteurs ferroviaires les
simplifications annoncées sont
illusoires la multiplication des
structures la complexification et
l'étanchéité des organisations vont
renforcer les difficultés du nécessaire
mutualisation c'est pourquoi nous
porterons des amendements allant dans le
sens d'une réelle unification du système
la définition d'une nouvelle ambition
pour le ferroviaire renvoie à la
nécessité de financement renforcé nous
porterons des amendements en faveur
d'une reprise de la dette ferroviaire
d'être colossale monsieur le rapporteur
par l'État afin de développer les
capacités de financement des réseaux
nous reviendrons sur l'exigence d'unité
du réseau et sur la préservation des
conditions de travail dans le monde
ferroviaire il y a presque un an au sein
de cette hémicycle nous vous demandions
de clarifier la position du gouvernement
considérant que la que libéralisation
régionalisation et maîtrise publique du
système provient n'était pas à priori
compatible et que le message envoyé par
votre gouvernement était
particulièrement brouillé nous
demandions des engagements précis sur
des financements nouveaux sur les
missions de service public assumés par
le groupe public ferroviaire notamment
en matière de rééquilibrage modal nous
demandions que les salariés du secteur
ferroviaire soient respectées à tout
cela nous n'avons pas eu de réponse
aussi peu quant au respect des salariés
le traitement médiatique de la grève a
été particulièrement violent et
lamentable alors même et vous le savez
monsieur le ministre que les salariés du
rail défendent en toute responsabilité
et avant tout le service public nous
proposerons donc clairement au travers
nos amendements de renforcer ce groupe
public ferroviaire ce qui vous nous
accorderez constitue bien l'enjeu
décisif pour ce secteur je vous remercie
merci madame la sénatrice dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à madame Anne-Marie Escoffier pour le
groupe rdsa
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Messieurs les Présidents des
commissions des finances et du
développement durable monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues voilà
qu'arrive dans notre Haute Assemblée un
texte nourri par une actualité récente
forte et plusieurs événements qui ont
suscité émotion et interrogations tant
chez nos amis cheminots qu'après de nos
concitoyens nous tous avons en mémoire
le terrible accident de Brétigny nous ne
pouvons oublier les embarras duo
dernière grève nous nous sommes
interrogés sur la largeur des quais trop
étroit pour accueillir les nouvelles
rames de train moderne j'ai
volontairement mis pêle-mêle des
événements qui sont d'un ordre bien
différent
s'agissant de Brétigny monsieur le
ministre à votre demande a été
dirigeante une enquête dans les
premières dont les premières analyses
sont terrifiantes coupables négligence
état de délabrement jamais vu des mots
qui font froid dans le dos qui heurtent
les voyageurs habituels ou potentiels
qui blesse aussi notre conscience
l'affaire de la largeur des quais et peu
de choses en vérité rapporté au drame
humain que je viens de rappeler
peut-être n'a-t-on pas assez souligné
que le fait était connu maîtrisé et que
l'on ne saurait faire griève à la SNCF
d'avoir voulu moderniser son matériel
roulant pour améliorer le confort de ces
passagers et le mettre aux normes de
l'accessibilité pour handicaper
la grève des cheminots enfin récurrentes
faites pour alerter on ne saurait lui en
faire le reproche si l'on veut bien
entendre les inquiétudes des personnels
concernés mais on comprend bien aussi
l'agacement des usagers pris en otage
une nouvelle fois et insuffisamment
informé des raisons de ce blocage
j'ai moi-même il y a quelques jours
seulement en Aveyron reçu une délégation
de cheminot qui est venue me dire ces
questions et c'est demander si le projet
de réforme ferroviaire apporter des
solutions pérennes aux problèmes que je
dis en vrac de la dette les cheminots
consacreraient un jour sur 7 de leur
activité à rembourser la dette de la
durée d'amortissement des
investissements 10 ans est-ce
raisonnable de l'excessif cloisonnement
des activités insuffisamment
coordonnées et générant parfois de vrais
incohérences de la réduction du nombre
d'agents soulevant parfois des problèmes
de sécurité en secteur diffus de
l'ouverture à la concurrence inscrite
dans le principe à terme à moyen terme
des trains d'équilibre et du
vieillissement des matériels remorqués
des investissements prévus dans le Plan
Rail etc etc sans parler des questions
d'organisation plus locales et je cite
là aussi en vrac le maintien du train de
nuit de Rodez à Paris pourtant aussi
utile du maintien de la ligne Rodez
tout cela en lien avec la région
toutes ces questions
témoignent d'un véritable désarroi
auquel j'ai voulu répondre en soulignant
la qualité du dialogue établit entre
notre assemblée et votre ministère
monsieur le ministre avec les différents
partenaires aussi qui se sont exprimés
en toute spontanéité et transparence
répondant ainsi aux questionnements
éclairés de notre excellent rapporteur
michel Teston et de notre rapporteur
monsieur Patriat dont je voudrais saluer
ici la qualité des travaux et la qualité
des travaux de toutes celles et ceux qui
ont apporté leur concours à la rédaction
du texte de la commission
un texte qui aujourd'hui
corrige les effets je dirais même les
méfaits de la loi du 13 février
1997 qui avait provoqué une stricte
séparation entre RF gestionnaire
d'infrastructures et la SNCF exploitant
et avait pour but plus ou moins
ouvertement déclinés de réduire la dette
de la SNCF
17 années sont passés sans que le
résultat recherché soit atteint et tout
le monde a pu mesurer le mur
d'incompréhension élevée entre les deux
opérateurs
remettre dans une seule main cohérente
sous la même autorité un épique de tête
les deux entités relèvent donc du bon
sens un bon sens encadré par la
réglementation européenne qui contraint
à distinguer clairement les missions de
définition des sillons de celle de
tarification c'est un point je crois
important sur lequel il nous faut
insister je veux dire combien j'ai été
convaincu par les propos de Monsieur
papy de Monsieur Pepy pardon par ceux de
Monsieur ravoport par les vôtres
monsieur le ministre du fait que vous
êtes allé aussi loin que possible en
termes d'intégration dans le strict
respect du droit vous me pardonnerez et
je ferai des excuses publiques à
Monsieur pepit dès que je le
rencontrerai
projet remet ainsi enfin un système de
gouvernance devenu complexe et peu
efficace sur la bonne voie
l'état l'État et vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le ministre assumera désormais
pleinement sa mission de guide
stratégique grâce à la majorité dont il
disposera au sein du conseil de
surveillance de l’épique mère le
renforcement des pouvoirs de l'Autorité
de régulation des activités ferroviaires
les règles d'impartialité applicable à
ses membres la vie qu'elle devra rendre
sur l'organisation interne au sein de SS
SNCF réseau sont autant de gages de
bonnes gestion et de bonnes
administration
la création d'un Haut Comité du
ferroviaire dont vous avez longuement
parlé là aussi Monsieur le Ministre
permettant de réunir l'ensemble des
acteurs et la traduction de cette belle
volonté de fédérer toutes les forces et
de chercher ensemble les meilleures
solutions aux problèmes structurels qui
se posent
je ne peux oublier de souligner parce
que c'est un point essentiel de notre
débat et qui a souvent fait l'objet de
discussion entre nous les garanties
apportées dans le volet social un cadre
social modernisé des règles de travail
ouvertes à tous les salariés la garantie
de vouloir écarter le risque d'un
nivellement par le bas des conditions de
travail des employés et cheminots de la
SNCF
c'était un pari difficile
un pari aboutit selon moi
il n'en reste pas moins monsieur le
ministre et j'ai bien entendu que vous
avez voulu écarter ou réduire les
interrogations que vous avez entendu ou
si elle a ici ou là que les
préoccupations majeures qui planent sur
ce projet de loi tiennent à la question
financière d'une part à l'ouverture à la
concurrence d'autre part
avec le gouvernement sur la base des
analyses temps de SNCF que de FF nous
savons l'ampleur du déficit de la SNCF
un déficit que dans votre stratégie vous
envisagez de stabiliser le mot est
important au niveau de 60 milliards en
2025 l'intention la stabilisation est
certes louable mais sa réduction serait
encore plus ambitieuse et elle est moins
assurée la question se pose
véritablement des moyens déterminés
persévérant qui seront mises en œuvre
pour tendre vers une véritable
efficience de notre système
nous n'ignorons pas les deux aléas
auxquels le gouvernement est soumis
celui d’abord
et le rapporteur de la le président de
la commission des finances l'a dit tout
à l'heure le premier celui de la
conjoncture économique la baisse de
trafic provoquant une moindre rentrée
financière pour FF malgré les
augmentations de pH auquel il avait été
procédé et en même temps la dépréciation
de ses actifs TGV pour un montant de 1
milliard 400 millions à laquelle SNCF
s'est vu contrainte pour ses comptes
2013 le deuxième aléa c'est celui des
taux d'intérêt la probable remontée du
loyer de l'argent tout comme la
persistante inquiétante d'une inflation
très modeste ne peuvent pas manquer de
nous interroger
monsieur Pepi lui-même ne disait-il pas
devant les membres de la commission de
développement durable les taux d'intérêt
sont très bas s'il remonte nous serons
en situation de surendettement
j'en viens maintenant sur le point de
l'ouverture à la concurrence point
important d'interrogation dans nos
débats important tant nous voudrions
déjà en connaître le calendrier et les
modalités je ne crois pas
utile pour ma part dans les
circonstances actuelles de vouloir déjà
en définir les contours je crois sage
prudent et raisonnable de se préparer à
cette ouverture dans le cadre d'un
calendrier qui reste à négocier le
quatrième paquet début 2015 devrait en
être l'occasion et je suis sûr monsieur
le ministre pour vous connaître un peu
que vous mettrez tout en oeuvre dans le
cadre de vos réunions à la Commission
européenne pour maîtriser pour maîtriser
parfaitement un sujet qui nécessite
détermination et conviction à la fois
pour soutenir notre modèle français
je souhaite enfin saluer l'avancée
conséquente voir la chaèvement de la
régionalisation ferroviaire qui
souffrait jusqu'à maintenant de
ressources insuffisantes et
d'incohérence manifeste
personne ici n'ignore les efforts qui
ont dû être démultipliés par les régions
pour se substituer à RFS en particulier
je les ai clairement mesurés dans ma
région mais je sais d'autres régions qui
se sentent aussi largement impliquées je
ne peux donc que me réjouir des
nouvelles dispositions permettant à la
région d'acquérir par transfert de
propriété des infrastructures de
transport ferreux voire de matériel
roulant la région trouvera alors toute
sa place toute sa responsabilité dans
l'une de ces compétences majeures
l'aménagement du territoire
autorité organisatrice de transport la
région sera désormais partie prenante à
l'ensemble des débats
monsieur le ministre notre débat viendra
j'en suis sûr encore éclairé les
avancées de ce texte dont vous avez
longuement largement développer les 5
axes majeurs avec mes amis du groupe
erdse auquel je l'honneur d'appartenir
nous sommes conscients des fragilités
qui peuvent demeurer encore mais nous
sommes confiants dans la capacité de
tous les partenaires de tous les
partenaires de faire évoluer
progressivement le système pour aller
vers un meilleur service public nous
voterons donc favorablement ce texte
merci madame la ministre
pour le groupe écologiste de la parole
est à Monsieur Ronan Dantec
Monsieur Madame madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur cher michel Teston chers
collègues vous le savez pour les
écologistes le train et sa gouvernance
font toujours l'objet d'une attention
particulière et l'examen de ce projet de
loi porte toutes les questions de son
avenir c'est donc une discussion très
importante qui s'ouvre ici au Sénat nous
avons aujourd'hui des trains à plusieurs
vitesses et des passagers qui ne
bénéficient pas tous des mêmes qualités
de service pour certains ce train est
synonyme de déplacement rapide et
confortable il est une des incarnations
de la modernité et du dynamisme de leur
territoire
mais pour bien des usagers au quotidien
des trains de bonlieues ou de certaines
liaisons régionales il est aussi le
symbole d'une France délaissée qui se
mesure en fatigue fatigue engendrées par
la modernisation insuffisante du
matériel et des réseaux voire de son
usure sévère pour ne pas utiliser des
mots plus durs qui font aujourd'hui
débats et ce sans compter aussi les
difficultés anciennes du dialogue social
au sein de l'entreprise qui sont aussi
génératrices de difficultés pour les
usagers défaut d'entretien problème
d'organisation de la maintenance et de
coordination entre SNCF et RFF et nous
en avons tous concrètement des exemples
les difficultés actuelles sont connues
et assez partagées même si dans le cas
de l'accident de Brétigny que nous avons
évidemment encore tous en tête et avec
une pensée pour les victimes c'est bien
à la justice de dire aujourd'hui les
responsabilités
cette analyse d'une organisation non
satisfaisante ne date pas d'hier
nécessite des réponses en termes
d'organisation j'y reviendrai dans
quelques instants mais elle dit aussi la
nécessité de nous réinterroger sur les
priorités d'investissement ainsi si les
écologistes se sont opposés à la
politique du tout TGV et au lion Turin
par exemple ce n'est pas pour bloquer le
développement du transport ferroviaire
mais bien au contraire et les évolutions
récentes le confirment pour le sauver
comment aujourd'hui garantir et
développer un service public de qualité
et accessible à tous on nous avons dû
les nouvelles LGV sous couvert de course
à la vitesse et de développement
métropolitain mais dans la situation de
raréfaction de l'argent public
disponible à quel prix pour le réseau
existant celui qui maille les
territoires et sert les usagers au
quotidien en toute cohérence donc nous
avons défendu nous écologistes face à
des projets parfois pharaoniques le
train a au niveau de service déjà très
rapide de 120 km/h quand même mais
nécessitant des investissements beaucoup
moins lourds et s'inscrivant ainsi dans
une logique donnant la priorité à la
rénovation des lignes existantes et
limitant l'endettement la dette
historique de SNCF RFF en effet même si
elle n'entre pas dans les critères de
Maastricht et dans la dette de l'État ne
peut en effet être
occulté elle s'élève aujourd'hui cela a
été dit bien avant moi à hauteur d'une
quarantaine de milliards d'euros en
hausse de 1 milliard 5 par an 2,2
milliards en 2013 et avec un objectif
gouvernemental de contenir cette dette
autour de 60 milliards à l'horizon 2025
ça donne un peu le vertige comment
éviter la paralysie du système avec une
dette aussi lourde et ce d'autant que
l'activité ferroviaire a ralenti en 2013
- 2 % pour le transport de voyageurs
c'est un signal assez alarmant - 3% pour
le frais comment faire alors que les LGV
qui viennent d'être lancés sous le
gouvernement précédent plombe les contes
de l'entreprise le rapporteur sur la
réforme ferroviaire Gilles Savary dit
d'ailleurs à ce propos je le cite que
les lignes à grande vitesse sont un
joujou français qui ne fonctionne qu'en
dégradant les contes de la SNCF et en
endettant RFR c'est un méditer face à
ces projets donc et dans la situation
budgétaire critique où nous sommes les
écologistes réaffirment l'importance de
fléchir en priorité les financements
vers l'aménagement et la rénovation des
villes existantes plutôt que vers le
déploiement de nouvelles lignes certes
monsieur le ministre vous avez rappelé à
juste titre le plan modernisation doté
de 410 millions d'euros qui vient d'être
lancé mais nous craignons quand même que
cela soit insuffisant et nous ne pouvons
que le comparer aux sommes allouées par
exemple à ce fameux tunnel Lyon Turin
c'est-à-dire plus de 14 milliards
d'euros cela ne nous semble pas
aujourd'hui raisonnable
même logique une certaine logique
s'applique aussi aux frais de
ferroviaire l'absence de rénovation des
réseaux capillaires l'absence
d'investissement suffisant de la part de
l'état de la SNCF ou de RF nous empêche
de développer une véritable stratégie de
report modal pourtant dans toutes les
discours et pourtant nécessaire pour
répondre aux grands enjeux climatiques
liés au transport je rappelle
qu'effectivement la France adore
souligner que sur sa production
d'électricité elle est assez peu et
maîtrise de gaz à effet de serre nous
connaissons l'histoire mais elle ne
rappelle pas autant à quel point sur la
question des transports le bilan en
termes de gaz à effet de serre français
et tout à fait désastreux et ne sait pas
améliorer ces dernières années il faut
donc des financements innovants pour les
transports le péage poids lourd est en
train d'être remis sur les rails si je
peux me permettre quand même très
mauvais jeu de mots c'est une nouvelle
positive et monsieur le ministre nous
sommes déjà partant pour réaugmenter
rapidement le réseau taxable nous avons
gardé le système nous n'avons gardé que
4 5000 km il sera assez simple de
réaugmenter assez rapidement et il y a
déjà des propositions dans certains de
régions le niveau du réseau taxable dans
un contexte de budget de l'État
contraint particulièrement concernant
les transports nous considérons aussi
que les régions doivent obtenir les
moyens de leur politique c'est ainsi que
nous appelons à donner aux régions une
plus grande autonomie fiscale c'est un
élément constant du discours des
écologistes nous avons ainsi défendu sur
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative des amendements pour créer
une part régionale de taxes sur le
transit poids lourd alors nous avons
évidemment pas pu la défendre jusqu'au
bout nous y reviendrons mais monsieur le
ministre nous sommes toujours disposés
en discuté pour la prochaine loi de
finances je crois que dans le contexte
actuel avec aussi ce transfert vers les
régions de nouvelles compétences
transports il faut absolument que nous
trouvons de nouvelles recettes pour les
régions et en gardant le système tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui avec la
participation de l'État à ecomouves il
ne sera pas très compliqué de rajouter
pour la part du réseau de route qui est
de la responsabilité des régions en
termes d'aménagement d'investissement et
d'entretien une part taxable je crois
que c'est une discussion que nous devons
avoir en conservant le système actuel
sur le présent projet de loi notre
commission a adopté un amendement
porter notamment par Roland risque
créant une part régionale de versement
transport interstitiel nous vous
inviterons à aller plus loin en décidant
d'y ajouter une part de VTT
additionnelle un taux maîtrisé nous
avons proposé 0,2 % et dans le cas
j'insiste là-dessus du maintien d'un
plafond de VT à 2%. nous savons tous que
nous avons ici une véritable difficulté
puisque une part des habitants des
agglomérations bénéficient des étoiles
ferroviaires donc que les agglomérations
participent à ce financement serait
logique j'entends bien la question de ne
pas augmenter le taux de VT j'entends
bien la difficulté de négociation entre
les agglomérations et les régions mais
je crois là qu'il y a une vraie question
sur la table sur lequel il faudra
chercher des solutions donner des marges
de manœuvre budgétaire aux régions sera
d'autant plus justifiée que celle-ci
sont appelés à prendre plus d'importance
dans l'organisation de l'ensemble des
politiques de transport avec les
compétences de la loi le branchu j'ai
bien entendu Mireille cherche parler
tout à l'heure de régionalisation du
transport ferroviaire je pense que c'est
un petit peu exagéré mais je voudrais
quand même assister sur le fait que
régionalisation ne rime pas avec des
membres mots du service public c'est
aussi un renforcement de l'action
publique et ça n'est pas parce qu'on est
au niveau régional et pas seulement au
niveau de l'État que nous ne sommes pas
dans le service public et l'action
publique c'est pourquoi également sur ce
projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire les
écologistes visent donc à renforcer la
place des régions dans la gouvernance de
la future entêté SNCF nous avons un
petit peu gagné à l'Assemblée nationale
sur ce point je rappelle que les régions
assurent aujourd'hui les deux tiers du
financement public du système
ferroviaire il nous semble que trois
représentants des régions au conseil de
surveillance de la SNCF nous semblerait
utile et raisonnables on sait déjà qu'il
y aura le représentant de la région
parisienne donc il y ait deux
représentants de région en dehors de la
région parisienne ça ne serait pas
absurde au niveau du financement
aujourd'hui des régions et de leur
engagement sur ce sujet alors je sais
bien qu'il faut faire des comptes sur
derrière les équilibres de ce conseil de
surveillance mais je pense que nous
pouvons y arriver en parallèle nous
soutenons très clairement le fait que
l'État soit conforté dans son rôle
stratégique au sein du futur groupe
ferroviaire réunifié la planification
des investissements le pilotage
stratégique est cohérent des politiques
de mobilité est essentielles dans un
moment je l'ai dit où nous avons des
choix déterminants à opérer sur la
réservation la résorption pardon de la
dette la hiérarchisation des
investissements la réponse aux enjeux
écologiques au vu de l'importance de ces
sujets et nous croyons que la
représentation nationale a aussi un rôle
à jouer dans la définition des objectifs
à moyen et long terme il nous semble
important d'aller vers une loi
d'orientation quinquennale en matière de
mobilité soumise au Parlement je crois
qu'on a été plusieurs à portée des
amendements en ce sens
si la loi n'est pas possible nous
pourrions nous inspirer de ce que nous
avons fait dans le cadre de la loi sur
la transition énergétique avec une
programmation pluriannuelle validée par
le Parlement et qui s'imposerait à
l'opérateur historique c'est le schéma
qui est aujourd'hui alors évidemment pas
encore adopté mais c'est le schéma qui
est dans la loi sur la transition et
énergétique dans ce cas là cette
programmation ne portrait évidemment pas
que sur le ferroviaire mais sur la
mobilité vu comme un ensemble de
politiques publiques convergence c'est
évidemment une question essentielle
aujourd'hui réintégrant donc le rail
dans la question plus large de la
mobilité
pour des raisons parfois assez proches
en jeu environnementaux et nécessité de
hiérarchiser finement les
investissements au vu des masses
financières en jeu rappelle que
finalement nous parlons transition
énergétique nous devrions aussi parler
de transition des mobilités un mot enfin
sur le dialogue social au sein de
l'entreprise je crois que nous serons
nombreux ici à considérer que la SNCF
est un socle du service public à la
française que cette conscience de la
mission de service public est très forte
parmi les cheminots et les personnels
que c'est une forme de patrimoine
français qui ne doit pas se dégrader au
rythme du matériel roulant ou des voies
l'ensemble est totalement lié j'ai
apprécié la phrase forte de Mireille
search des valeurs qui simendent le
territoire je l'ai noté je la partage
même si peut-être s'agirait plus de
mieux irriguer le territoire que de le
cimenter mais je crois que l'idée est
forte nous la partageons donc nous
serons vigilants sur le éviter
strictement une ouverture à la
concurrence qui se fasse sur la base
d'un dumping social dont l'exemple du
transport routier nous dit aujourd'hui
les risques ce qui ne veut pas dire
immobilise de l'entreprise nous avons
aussi parlé dans le débat général des
gains de productivité à faire et je veux
quand même rappeler que en terme de
concurrence la première question c'est
la concurrence du transport routier
aujourd'hui que c'est là-dessus que se
joue aussi l'avenir du fret de
ferroviaire et de la SNCF donc il faut à
la fois des gains de productivité mais
aussi éviter le dumpick social y compris
dans le transport routier pour l'avenir
de la SNCF et du système ferroviaire
français je crois que dans le débat qui
a eu lieu à l'Assemblée nationale un
certain nombre de garanties ont été
donnés au personnel et à leur syndicats
sur leur participation à la gestion de
la nouvelle entreprise de cette nouvelle
organisation donc je crois que là dessus
le travail de l'Assemblée nationale a
été important était même peut-être plus
vite que ce qui était prévu initialement
mais je crois que c'était tout à fait
essentiel de donner des garanties en
termes de gestion collectif dans cette
gestion collective et je vais en finir
là la place des usagers et des
associations de protection
d'environnement et aussi très
importantes à côté de l'état des
salariés et des régions l'article
l141-2 prévoit que ces associations sont
appelées à participer à l'action des
organismes publics concernant
l'environnement je crois que ce serait
important de s'en rappeler concernant la
SNCF ce projet de loi de réforme
ferroviaire et donc bienvenue Caro une
réforme en profondeur du système
ferroviaire était devenu plus que
nécessaire nous la voterons donc
toutefois les écologistes considèrent
qu'il existe encore des marges
d'amélioration de ce texte nous espérons
que le débat nous quittons l'hémicycles
du Sénat mais nous allons bien entendu
revenir plus haut largement sur les
enjeux de la réforme ferroviaire avec
nos invités dans 24 heures Senna le
journal c'est tout de suite